I felt that I'd be willing to do a
podcast with fresh back from Brazil
within hours of landing on sacred
American soil,
but you're one of them,
Josh stuff live.
It's a real pleasure to be back.
Thanks.
Bye Man.
What?
So first of all,
well,
let me say the last time I was here,
I was like,
out of it.
I was,
I was white knuckling it just.
I was hung over.
I was tired.
It was 10 in the morning.
I hadn't slept probably.
I'd been on like a late night flight
from New York.
I was sick.
Joe.
I didn't know you were sick.
You,
you performed admirably?
Yeah,
I tried.
I tried to kill it today.
Shit.
I'm just going to smash it.
Week one today.
Yeah.
Good.
I'll,
I'll pick it up.
Thank you.
We'll just switch switch roles.
You can sit back and I'll ask you
questions.
Yeah.
How you feeling?
Question to my own expectations.
My own of my own self.
Just maybe travel like long trips before
every podcast.
What?
Uh,
what was Brazil about a.
The UFC great.
Ronda rousey fight.
Excellent.
Pretty crazy time.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
It was,
I'm watching her fight is like a.
it's like watching some historical
thing.
It's like I was saying like when people
tell their grandchildren.
I was there when Muhammad Ali fought
Sonny Liston,
know I was there when Mike Tyson beat
Trevor Berbick and won the heavyweight
title.
Yeah.
That's what it feels like when you watch
her fight,
like you're not just seeing a fight.
You're watching some crazy historic
event.
It's amazing.
She's an.
She's just a freak.
It was like a freak of all freaks.
Beautiful Woman Who's just this insane,
furious combat athlete.
Nuts.
You're the one who's just stepped off a
13 hour flight and is now working all
afternoon,
so that's good too.
That's hard.
Especially doing this.
Yeah,
that's true.
We haven't.
We have pretty easy jobs just sitting
around talking to people all day in.
We do,
we do,
but I really enjoy your show,
man.
You have some excellent interviews.
Did you interview that Peter Singer guy?
Yeah.
That's the Animal Liberation Liberation
Guy.
He founded the.
He coined the term animal liberation and
he sort of invented the.
He's one of the world's most important
bioethicists.
Like I mean in terms of just thinking
about the morality,
he's such a brilliant guy.
He's as if it's like an alien just came
down to width and said,
all right,
we're not going to have any more
preconceptions about what people think
is right and wrong.
We're going to start from basics and
think,
okay,
why do we think about the morality of
things the way that we do and how,
in what ways is that wrong?
So like he ends up with these crazy
conclusions and people like hate him.
For some of them,
like saying it's not necessarily wrong
to say kill an infant,
a newborn infant.
Well,
how does he justify that?
I think it's on the grounds that what's
wrong with killing something as a sort
of combination of snuffing out the life
of,
of a,
of a being that has the capability of
conceiving of itself as having a future.
Right?
You're thwarting a person's plans when
you kill them,
you're robbing them of all of the
opportunities that they hoped that they
were gonna have and you're presumably
causing them pain.
But if you could painlessly.
I mean,
if you don't,
if you think of life as being an
incremental thing that starts from a
conception and then gradually evolves up
into adulthood and sort of self
awareness and consciousness.
I mean does it two day old baby have
that much more sentience and
consciousness and sense of itself than a
22 week old baby in the womb does not a
huge amount necessarily.
I mean,
I'm not saying I agree with it,
but he just,
he's just a fascinating person to talk
to.
Does he have children?
Yeah,
I think so.
That's interesting that he thinks that
wavy as children because I could see it
if you're,
if you're trying to make some sort of a
logic argument,
you know,
that you could,
you could argue it like that,
but as far as like being a human being,
the difference being significant in that
a child represents potential and child
represents to a lot of people represents
this insane bond of love that you have
with the baby.
I,
you know,
I think just to clarify,
I think he's only saying like in cases
where,
you know,
the parents don't want it or something.
I mean he's,
he's not.
Obviously if you kill someone else's
baby,
you're doing a terrible thing because
you're depriving the parents of the kid,
right?
Oh,
they're saying like if they don't want
their baby,
it's not that big a deal in a situation
like a Bush as if it was like an
abortion.
There's some people that are extreme
animal rights folks that also believed
that there's something about if you did
kill a person,
at least you stopped that person from
killing all the animals.
They're going to kill or be responsible
for the death of in their entire life,
which is,
which gets real insane.
That's kind of crazy.
I don't think he'd agree with that.
Well,
you want to know real crazy,
the lobster liberation movement?
No.
Yes,
no.
Yes.
There's people that
break into restaurants or places that
have seafood and keep lobsters and they
released them and take the rubber bands
off.
They're atrophied clause and release
them back into the ocean.
Those
lobsters out stuff of heaven in the
ocean and they've had a too good for too
long.
It might not be stimulating being in the
lobster tank,
but it sure is safe.
I don't know if the lobsters eat while
they're in the tank.
That's a good question.
I don't know how they must be fed.
Right?
I don't.
I've never seen it,
if you will,
that wouldn't do it while you're eating
them.
But they always have the rubber bands on
their claws so they don't Jack each
other up while they were in that tank.
I'll probe on top of each other.
It is pretty.
I like,
I,
I'm.
It is kind of sick.
Like I,
I have no problem with it because I do
eat maintenance so I can't really be a
but could have added,
but I think there's something just kind
of oddly sadistic about sitting there at
a table and just being like,
alright,
I'm going to have that,
that I'm going to end that one's life
right now and then I'm just going to eat
him in front of his buddies.
Yeah.
Well we have a weird thing about.
We have like a hierarchy of animals that
we love and that's one of the things we
found out about Cecil.
Oh God,
let's say I want to get to,
I want to get to this.
It's definitely should get to it,
but we don't have any problem with even
vegans will slap a mosquito and it's
biting them like you don't have a
problem with that.
Not only that,
when bugs are really little,
like ants will kill it and then brush it
off our pants and leave the body on the
ground and it's just like a head on our
pants and just some little limbs.
Just crush out the grand bug guts and
then the aunt will be an.
I had a friend do that on my kitchen
once he had an aunt.
I was like,
oh fuck,
fucking aunt.
And he just brushed it on the ground.
I go,
isn't that odd that I don't have a
problem with you doing that,
but isn't it odd that we do that?
We just brushed bodies under our
friends' floors and we don't care about
it.
Just this week.
So getting back to Peter Singer,
his whole philosophy of animal
liberation is sort of that there is a
hierarchy of consciousness and sentience
that has to be taken into account.
He's,
if he happens to be a Vegan,
but he doesn't think,
you know,
I've spoken to him.
Obviously he doesn't think that an
oyster has the same right to life as a
lion does or as a chimpanzee does.
Right?
So you factor in the capacity of the,
of the creature to be sent to you and to
feel pain and to have a conception of
itself and to feel love and fear and
those sorts of things and how much it
does.
That's why human life is probably more
important than any other animal's life.
Maybe whales with dolphins.
So I don't know.
Some other animal.
It's equally smart as us,
but so for him the bugs are less worthy
and for anyone sensible the bugs out.
Right.
But what's interesting when you say like
we have these weird conceptions of our
own hierarchies of like cute animals and
non cute animals or animals that we give
a shit about mammals that we don't.
What's interesting is that that
hierarchy doesn't match up with a Peter
Singer with a logical ethical hierarchy,
like why are we so willing to be so
cruel to pigs,
which adjusts as conscious and self
aware and capable of love and family and
pain as dogs,
if not more so,
but we have these institutionalized
concentrated animal feeding operations
that just torture.
I mean it's torture.
I mean,
whatever that industry can do to lower
the price of a pound of flesh by a few
pennies,
it will do,
including anesthetizing the pigs,
get grabbing little piglets by the tile
and just smashing their heads against a
wall to kill them if they had,
if they're not viable anymore.
I mean it's an absolute murder show.
It's like a.
it's an ongoing holocaust of,
of,
of pigs,
but then like little people get arrested
for,
I don't know,
Michael Vick or something and you're
doing something bad for dogs.
We just don't give it.
Give a shit.
So what,
what paid a singer would say is yes,
there's a hierarchy,
but let's at least be sensible about the
hierarchy,
which brings us to settle.
Cecil Cecil was a 13 year old lion,
which I want everyone to understand that
if you're a male lion and you reach 13
years of age,
you have killed a fuck load of baby
lines.
Sure.
One hundred percent.
How many gazelles have you killed?
Lot of gazelles.
But also there's a lot of,
how do you say,
infanticide,
trust side,
fantasy,
side to
side.
It's not trunk.
I'm always want to make an r there for
some reason.
Well,
there are some other types of light
fratricide rise.
I think that's why infanticide,
if that is the correct way of saying
he's got no wisdom,
100 percent.
But I think that is,
uh,
that,
that's,
that's an important point to look.
My friend Steve Rinella calls them
charismatic megafauna and he's like,
there's all these animals that are
charismatic megafauna that we have
anthropomorphized in movies like the
lion king and Yogi bear and all these
movies and we have this idealized view
of what they really are.
But the reality of them is so alien to
us because we're never in Africa,
in Zimbabwe,
in the jungle with these lines.
And if you were,
you'd be absolutely fucking terrified of
them and you wouldn't think of them.
Like I saw Jimmy Kimmel crying on TV.
I was like,
Whoa,
Jimmy,
I want to show you some videos.
I'm going to show you some videos of
Cecil killing babies because apparently
there's a video of cecil actually
killing
the actual same lion.
Interesting.
Allegedly,
it might not be him.
It's hard to.
Yeah.
And it's also a condescending to the
people who live there.
Like,
I mean,
there are farmers there who were like,
well,
yeah,
you're allowed to be little teary about
a lion.
It eats out damn cows all the time.
Like,
or like elephants,
they just stomping all over our crops.
So yeah,
let's save them.
Absolutely.
But we should have a little bit more
empathy for the human beings who were
there to.
Yeah.
Well the human beings.
Here's the other one.
The poachers,
the lives of poachers.
Okay.
Now,
let's see.
I am not defending this guy.
I don't,
I'm not exactly sure what happened.
There are several different versions of
what that guy did and some of them are,
uh,
according to book.
They're,
they're,
they're fine in legal.
That's not the only line that's ever
been killed like this with a collar on
it.
When the lions are off the preserved
area,
it's legal to kill them.
That's right.
Not saying you should kill them.
Just saying if they're not there,
but here's the,
here's the thing.
But they lured him off.
I think that's the difference,
right?
Here's what's legal to kill as much as
you want poachers,
people,
they can kill people there every day.
Then when they have these hunting camps,
when they go out looking for lions or
more,
more often,
it's lions are fairly rare.
Most people,
when they go over there to hunt,
they want to hunt something to eat with
big antlers they could put on their
wall.
Yeah,
like a neeland or a gazelle or something
along those lines.
When they go to hunt those occasionally
they'll find people that are there and
they call these people poachers,
and what they are is extremely poor
people that are.
They're shooting these animals without a
permit and you know what they do,
they murder them.
They murdered these people on a regular
basis.
I have a friend who went over there for
a hunting camp and while he was there,
they,
the people that he was with shot a
poacher,
shot it right in front of them.
There was a man and that man had a,
uh,
a gun that was like a,
they have makeshift guns,
they have,
it's an actual gun,
but they don't have real bullets.
So what they do is they create a,
with like a piece of metal,
they find pieces of metal and they get
some gun powder and they create a firing
pin and they have to light it like a
musket.
It's crazy.
I mean these are extremely,
extremely poor people.
Not only that,
they find their camps and a lot of their
camps,
they'll find evidence of witchcraft.
So they have this white powder that
they'll find these camps and they put
this white powder on the wrists and they
believe this white powder.
It's been blessed by this switch.
Doctor makes them invisible.
So this guy was standing out in the
open,
like right next to a tree when the,
the,
the game wardens,
the people that live and work in Africa
and handle this stuff,
shot this guy,
they shot this guy and you know what
they do with them when they shoot them,
they fill out paperwork or they don't.
Sometimes they just feed them to the
hyenas.
And this happens every day and this
happens all the time because they have
these huge hunting preserves,
right?
So these preserves might be 20,
30,
40,000
acres,
maybe more enormous.
One of them,
my friend was onset.
It took eight hours to drive from one
side of the ranch to the other.
So you're talking about an enormous
piece of land.
And in this enormous beautiful land,
you'll find insanely poor people.
And these insanely poor people have
nothing.
There's no,
it's dry.
There's no supermarkets,
there's no,
no one,
no government support.
There's no where for them to go.
So what do they do?
They,
they take a risk and they go and try to
find animals to kill in these hunting
preserves and they get shot and they get
killed and no one gives a fuck.
Right.
So the economic,
the fund,
the underlying problem here is the
economics.
Exactly.
Right.
And there's another,
there's a case,
I mean some people say,
well look,
trophy hunting,
you may not agree with it,
but the $50,000
per person to spending can then go into
maintaining a preserve that actually
protects a whole bunch of of lions.
Now I'm a bit sort of conflicted about
that because there are only a few tens
of thousands of lines left,
right.
Even even fewer elephants at ink.
So there's some areas,
it depends on Africa.
There's some areas where they have to
call elephants because they have too
many of them.
Yeah,
I mean,
I mean that again,
that's because of the encroachment of
cities and more and more know losing so
much of their habitat.
You might have a lot of elephants in a
particular small area,
but overall the number is going down
dramatically across the content.
Yeah.
Well,
I was reading a piece the other day that
was saying that,
you know,
within within 15 or 20 years,
it's entirely possible they just won't
be any African elephants left.
Well before.
So forgive me for anybody who's
listening to this,
but Louis through has a great
documentary.
Yeah,
and I heard him on your show as well.
I'm a huge fan of Louis and I've seen
that episode a couple of times.
Well,
one of the things that was pointed out
in that show,
there was a lot of animals that were on
the verge of extinction that are now
thriving because they live in these
giant hunting camps that's really
fucked.
You look at it and that's what the guy
running the hunting camp said,
you know,
when,
when Louis was kind of confronting him
about this,
he goes,
listen to me,
I have an it guy to clocked.
Yeah,
that's an intense moment.
How incredible.
That guy saying that,
like,
Whoa,
like this.
This guy is like,
he's just at his wits end.
So Ricky Gervais' was coming on facebook
about the,
about cecil the lion and the trophy
hunting and everything.
Because he's a big animal rights guy and
he'd super opposed to trophy hunting and
he was saying like,
you know,
sure,
maybe this is going to fund something
better,
but would you allow some asshole to like
shoot a cancer patient if he was willing
to donate a million dollars to cancer
research?
That's not how.
It's not how it works.
If,
why doesn't the asshole who just donate
if he thinks he's doing a good deed to
fail lion conservation,
donate the $50,000
and then just don't kill a lion?
Well,
well he's,
he doesn't want that.
He wants to line in his house so he
could climb on top of it and jerk off to
it
and that's the whole point and I don't
know what he likes.
Then it comes back to like,
you know Jon Ronson,
you've had him on the show.
So you've been publicly shamed.
Guys love that guy.
By the way,
Bill Hader does the best John Ronson
impersonation you've ever heard.
I had bill hader and a judd apatow on
huff post live a couple of weeks ago and
for some reason we were just talking
about what books they like.
I don't remember how it came up and uh,
and Judd apatow was like,
I'm really into John Ronson and I kinda
thought that John was my special little
fetish I think is so great,
you know,
but he's not like an a list writer in
America at least I don't think that many
people know him.
And then Bill Hayden was like,
Oh yeah,
I just listened to the audiobook of his
book and I was like,
book and Bill Hader starts going
brilliant John Ronson infestation.
But anyway,
what happened to this guy who shot the
lion?
Reminds me a bit of what John is always
on about,
about like.
So he's had to shatter his dental
practice.
There's like a sign,
there were signs of abuse all over the
dental practice.
His big business has ruined.
He's had to go into hiding.
I mean,
is that fair?
Like should you.
Yeah,
he did a shitty thing.
I completely don't agree with,
I don't understand like trophy hunting.
I understand hunting,
hunting for meat,
but I don't understand trophy hunting,
uh,
but we all pile on and we all love being
so self righteous and so sanctimonious
about it at the same time,
once again,
as we're eating all those pigs that have
been tortured and people button into
chicken burgers that have been,
that that's another tortured animal,
but the moment there's something with a
big fluffy main and it has a cute name
like [inaudible].
Do you pronounce that name?
Cecil in America.
Is that Cecil?
Okay,
cool.
Sessile sounds better.
Yeah,
that's,
it's also like if the,
if the,
if the lion's name was like goth or
something,
I think people would be.
I was upset.
Sessile is the cutest name.
No one who's called sessile has ever
done anything wrong.
Wrong.
Cecil though is like a cool black guy
who hangs around pool halls.
You know,
Cecil can hook you up.
Cecil,
is it that?
Maybe that's where it cut may west.
That's where the pronunciation
difference comes from.
Does it come from African Americans?
That's interesting.
I don't know.
I don't know,
I mean there's a lot of different words
that they pronounced differently in
England.
Yeah,
that's true.
of course.
And in spelled differently
like tires of the why.
That's always bizarre when I read like
English auto mail,
auto magazines,
higher t y r e s,
m,
I think that the idea of this killing
this animal for no reason other than you
want to kill it because you like killing
things is what freaks everybody out.
The idea that this sociopath could go
over there and kill these beautiful
things.
Um,
and that's,
that's what freaks people out.
But what's going on right now?
Why this guy did this is people are
killing lions all over Africa.
Like,
here's really fucked up.
This is what's really fucked up.
There was an article that said that
Jericho,
Cecil's brother had also been killed by
line and everybody was like,
oh my God,
I can't believe this.
We lost Jericho.
This is crazy because it's Geragos got a
name and then they said it was a false
alarm.
Worry not,
it wasn't Jericho.
It was just some poor
line that doesn't have a name.
And then I'm like,
okay,
this kind of highlights what Rinella was
saying.
It's charismatic Megafauna,
you give them a name and all of a sudden
there's something significant about
them.
They they are.
They have a personality like Simba.
That's right.
I had to.
So I'm.
I'm out here in La this weekend doing an
episode of my new show.
I just launched a podcast,
which is a panel of three,
three comics sitting around talking
about the news each week.
What's it called?
It's called we the people live so people
can get.
You should follow us at a WTP under
school,
live on twitter.
Too much work or you already.
You just got off a plane.
I got other people who have like who
they are,
their brains to your list as a clever
enough,
there'll be able to write it down.
You say that you need to go on my
twitter and my facebook and read some
comments on instagram as well.
Or Youtube.
That's the fire pit.
That's the pit of stupidity or or you
can go to WTP livestock.
There's the other plug plug now,
but it's.
It's great.
It's a lot of fun.
So we had Greg Fitzsimmons on the,
on the show last night and uh,
we,
we just got a bunch of people together
in Hollywood and Fred Stoller who was a
writer on Seinfeld.
I don't know if you know,
Fred did a joke about exactly what you
were just saying about cecil the lion.
He was like,
it's like if someone like had intended,
like someone accidentally shot Bruce
Willis,
but they thought that we're gonna be
shooting like Gregory Mcgee and they're
like,
oh fuck,
I didn't realize that I was shooting
bruce.
Well,
I just thought I was going to be killing
this other random dude.
You'd still be like,
no,
you'd still murdered a guy.
Right?
It doesn't matter whether it's Jericho.
The shit hit the law and a,
the way was culpable.
People were
set that Jericho died and now they're
not upset because it was an unknown
line.
So no one is calling for the head of
this person that shot this unknown lion.
We're stupid.
We're very stupid,
but we're also ruined by media.
I really believe that media depictions
of animals and when you add human voices
to them,
like zookeeper movie that I was in,
you know,
you,
you do,
you do fuck with people's reality.
I think we're not designed to take in
the media.
I really don't believe that the human
body and brain is designed for films and
I think when we sit down there and we
watched some epic movie with lions,
like there was a movie called bears.
Did you ever see that movie?
Yeah.
That was a nature documentary.
Low was.
It was all over it.
There was another one called cats,
right?
That was recent and it was about big
cats.
They don't show what the fuck they
really do.
And the bear documentary,
they didn't show the bears killing cubs
or bears kill cubs.
Like that's what they'd like to eat.
That's one of the reasons why female
bears are so aggressive when they're
around their,
their babies.
Yeah.
That's.
It bears the Disney nature.
Film bears.
Yeah.
They didn't show that male bears come
out of hibernation and they go looking
for cubs first things they try to eat.
I mean,
I'm not sure that I buy your thesis that
things like animated movies like the
lion king screw us up,
but I do definitely think that if there
is something which is a pseudo
documentary like what you're talking
about,
like or something like one movie that I
hated,
I couldn't get through more than 20
minutes of it was march of the penguins.
Hi.
Had opened that about it.
I was angry about it.
Why?
Well,
there was a bunch of it.
One of the things that were mating for
life and I was like,
you know,
that they mate for life and they're
monogamous.
I'm like,
first of all,
they only meet for a year.
I'm like,
I could do that.
Second of all,
they look exactly the same.
It's not like one penguin is Jenna
Jameson Pega and the other ones that
rosie o'donnell,
penguin,
they're fucking penguins.
What's the point in cheating?
Just pretend you're
cheat.
It's like as if everyone was just
identical twins,
right?
Yeah.
Well it was also,
there was a part of the movie and this
really did happen when I watched it.
Um,
I was watching and there's those leopard
seals that feed off of the penguins that
I didn't even know existed.
I didn't even know it was a real animal
until that movie.
And it's this amazing piece of an animal
with these huge teeth.
And I was like,
whoa.
I was like,
this is incredible.
This thing's a wow.
And there was a family in front of me
and this mom was upset at me that I was
happy when the leopard seal was eating
the penguins.
I'm like,
what about the,
with the penguin is fucking slaughtering
these fish.
Like the hierarchy took.
There's a leopard seal right there.
Look at the fucking incredible beast of
what about the leopard sale?
It doesn't need to have a right to live.
Does not mean in all forms.
Can we up the star,
which is the penguin
march of a leopard seal,
Josh.
That's what I hated about it.
It was this,
it was a way of,
it was a total anthropomorphization,
if that's a word,
which probably isn't of,
of penguin life.
It's like it's,
it's portraying them as basically humans
in little costumes.
Right?
And it's creating all of these,
I mean clearly made up relation.
It would be like,
you know,
you'd see a shot of a penguin walking
away and it would be like I'm young.
Jimbo wandered off with a heavy heart to
think about,
to think about how he'd just been
jilted,
but like you have no idea what he's
probably wondering over there to take a
shit.
I don't know.
Taking this shit is trying to find some
fish to eat.
He's got three brain cells banging
around inside of stupid little bird
head.
Yeah.
So I think there is a.
I think like companies like Disney
probably should be held to better
account to be more responsible about
communicating to children the reality of
animal life rather than making it all
sunny.
Don't want their kids to watch.
Like pull up this video.
Jamie lion killing cub,
male lion killing cops.
I put this up on twitter and I thought
twitter took it down.
But what actually happened is I
retweeted somebody else tweeted it and
the guy who tweeted it got attacked so
hard that he decided to delete his
tweet.
He's just like,
fuck this.
Thanks a lot Joe.
It was just too much,
but the reason why he got in trouble is
because there's line is killing cubs.
It's this is reality and it's not just
an isolated instance.
Like a line.
A screw loose is one on a baby killing
rampage.
This is what they do when a lion takes
over a pride,
one of the first things he does after he
chases out,
go ahead,
play it.
Jimmy.
One of the first things he does after he
chases out the male line is kill all of
its babies.
Of course.
And this is what's going on right here.
Genetics.
I mean,
I,
I interviewed Richard Dawkins recently
as well,
and I've got another event coming up
with him in,
in October,
which is going to be cool.
And He,
you know,
he wrote the selfish gene,
meaning like the unit of evolution is
not the individual and it's not the
species,
it's the gene.
Now that line is killing those cubs
because what better way to make sure
that it's genes ended up getting passed
on and spread out and procreated through
the,
the um,
the extended the pride.
There's no better by making sure that
all of the other babies from the other
guys
don't go.
I mean,
he's just following instincts.
That's why wouldn't you.
This is part of the picture,
and again,
I'm not in favor of killing lions and
people say,
this is cecil by the way.
I don't know if that's true.
I mean how it,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know,
but they.
Cecil has been studied.
I mean these are part of an Oxford study
or was.
Yeah,
yeah.
I interviewed the,
the actually the head of that study,
the Oxford Guy.
Fascinating stuff that looks different
because he's younger in this video and
apparently when they get older they get
the black around their main.
I don't know if that's true,
but,
but bottom line is this is also part of
the picture,
so by showing only the beautiful aspects
of the line with flowing main walking
amongst the cubs that are his and the
female lionesses.
You don't see the actual whole animal.
You don't see the thing.
You also don't see the reality of the
poaching and what these people go
through that lived there and they and
then it's easy for these hunting wardens
to murder those people that are trying
to survive today is so much more
disturbing.
Yeah,
but then there's this big question.
I mean,
so there's the.
There's the ethics of actually taking
the lives of these animals and the
hypocrisy of loving dogs,
but not pigs and of eating chicken,
but then going crazy about cecil the
lion,
but then at the end of the day,
I always come back to the fundamental
fact that we are living through one of
the greatest extinction events in
history that's been unleashed by humans.
If in 50 years time we don't want to
live in a world that has no lines,
has no African elephants,
has totally polluted overfished waters
where you kind of eat tuna anymore
because there's so much mercury
in it.
Like we've got to find ways of dealing
with this and if the poachers are part
of that problem.
I'm not saying you put a bullet in the
head,
but you got to do something.
See with approaches that are getting
killed in Africa though most,
I mean there's different types of
poachers.
There's poachers in Africa that are
killing elephants for their ivory and
it's.
This is the most unbelievably brutal
aspect of it.
When poachers kill elephants for their
ivory,
the amount of ivory that they get,
they get like four or five elephants
that they kill.
I think they they.
There was a big story a few days ago
where they killed five elephants and
they,
they just chop off their tusks and leave
there.
The bodies to rot.
They got like $200 for those tusks and
those tests on the black market are
worth tens of thousands of dollars,
but that's fucking crazy.
I mean this is not hearing,
but you're also talking about people
that are just so fucking desperate.
We can't even understand the pint,
but there are a lot of desperate people
are a lot of desperate people born
desperate.
They're stuck.
There's,
I mean,
if you're in that environment.
I have a friend,
his name is Justin wren and he.
He'll be on the podcast soon again.
He's been on a few times.
He was,
he still was an mma fighter,
but he went over there.
I'm on a trip and met some pygmies in
the Congo and fell in love and just was
like,
I need to help these people and we've
been donating money and they've been
building wells.
They've built 16 wells for these people.
They're.
They're bringing in medical supplies and
doing all these things to try to help
these people,
but his.
The feeling that he got when he was
there,
it's like there's no one helping these
folks.
They asked to do anything they can to
survive.
These people that are on these hunting
preserves that they're calling poachers,
a lot of them are just trying to feed
themselves.
They're just.
There's no where to go.
There's nothing.
There's no options and it's legal to
kill those people and then the idea that
it's someone legal,
it is legal in Africa to kill these
people.
It's not legal.
It's legal.
Yes it is.
It might.
They might turn a blind eye to it.
It's always.
It's always illegal to kill them.
I'm telling you,
it's not really.
It's not in Africa.
A poacher.
You can shoot a poacher when they are on
your property and it's legal,
you fill out paperwork and you're done.
And it not only that,
but he was being done by what they call,
they call them professional hunters,
but they're essentially game wardens.
So like if you were um,
you know,
uh,
if you were in Montana,
oh,
you were elk hunting and you,
when you shoot an animal you have to
have a tag for it,
which means in Indian state allows
shooting tiger poachers on site offers
money to informants.
Yeah.
India in India,
right?
Yeah.
But yeah,
but it's the same thing.
It's not,
it's not uncommon to be for it to be
legal to shoot poachers,
but that's because they're down to only
like a few thousand lines or a few
thousand times.
In ancient India it might be even less
than thousands.
It might be like hundreds of of tigers
in India.
But point being it's not just legal like
it's done every day.
Everyday.
Africa is so big.
This is the other thing that people
need.
We,
we have this perception,
our head that Africa is something like
America,
you know,
well we know what life is like in
America,
so we expect life is like that in
Africa.
So if these people are over there in
Africa and they're shooting lions,
these are terrible people.
We the same sanely hard place to live.
Insanely awful place.
You have a lot of ways,
many,
many parts.
I think people know that.
I don't think people have any illusions
about what Africa is like.
The only time we see Africa on the news
is when some horrible,
horrible shit goes down.
Or when Bono is playing some,
some,
some charity concert to raise money for
them.
I think if anything,
I mean I've got friends who live in
Nairobi and there are lots of things
going.
I mean the bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation is doing all kinds of stuff.
There are lots of,
there's lots of entrepreneurship.
Cell phones have have revolutionized the
continent because all of a sudden people
are able to like send a text message to
the market that's three,
a three hour walk away and ask what,
what price?
You know,
fish or rice or getting that day and
they can actually plan instead of just
guessing like there.
There are a lot of good news stories in
Africa.
I'm not downplaying how terrible it is,
but the idea that the only way that you
can survive on the continent of Africa
is by poaching is by being an ivory
poachers.
Come on.
These are the people who are saying food
poachers.
These people,
these were that are getting shot in
these game preserves.
A lot of them are just hunting gazelles
or something along those lines.
Right?
Just hunting for food.
They have nothing.
Mom,
what I'm saying is I know all these
stories.
I'm aware of all these stories.
I read them all the time,
but I think unless you have feet on the
ground in Africa,
unless you actually go there and
experience it firsthand.
Everybody that I've talked to that's
been there,
so it is another world.
You might as well be on the mobile with
the Moon,
the moon.
You can be on the phone as well on that.
I think I know the information,
but I think I haven't internalized it
and that's what happened to my friend
Justin when he went there,
he just just like,
Jesus Christ,
I got to do something and he was just
struck with it because I don't,
I don't think.
I think don't think it gets in.
I think the information hits the brain.
It stores it,
you know,
one plus one is two.
It's like it's all there,
but unless you were there,
I don't think you could truly understand
what,
what that place is like.
Yeah.
But I think that's probably true and
we're also so caught up in,
in our own little worlds.
I mean especially in this country
because America is so big and it's so
easy to,
to maintain just live inside of the
American cultural bubble essentially
that it's not,
it's you have to actively proactively
try to seek out other sources of
information and other experiences.
Otherwise it's very easy to just coast
along here and not really think about
the rest of the world.
It's also kind of ironic that the last
big lion story that came out of Africa
was the editor from the game of thrones.
It got pulled out of her car by a lion.
She was taking a photograph of it and
the lion was like,
Ooh,
I think that's an open window.
Just dove into the car and literally
pulled her out in front of her friends
and they're all screaming and the lion
killed her right in front of everybody
and that's what they do.
They're fucking killers.
They're nature's cleanup crew.
Anything with a limp,
anything that looks like it's easy to
take out,
you know,
the thing that they didn't even eat her,
they just killed her.
It was killer for a goof.
Tied over,
taking pictures.
It's like shocks like to just say the
aussie surfer that was crazy and
attacked by a great white and like the,
the whole point like.
So sharks don't like what we taste like
right when they're to after big fatty
seals,
they don't like scrawny humans.
We're all bound in sin you.
And so they'll just take a bite to see
if they like us and then they'll spit us
out.
But if it's a nine foot great white,
then that little taste is enough to kill
you if they rip off your leg or a torso.
So I've always felt like,
especially as an Australian,
were that this was constantly just in
the background of your mind as a
possibility if we.
Because we're always at the beach,
like I would prefer it if they actually
liked us.
So at least one of us is happy and it's
just the ignominy of Bay of both being
killed.
And then also the shock being like,
Eh,
I didn't even like it.
Fuck you sean.
Well they,
they are the ultimate cleanup crew.
They're just dead behind the eyes.
Black Marbles for eyeballs.
Love Him.
I was like a shock nerd as a kid.
Books about sharks and would always.
Yeah,
because I don't really go in there.
I don't,
I don't surf.
But apparently surfing in South Africa
is like fucking jogging.
Were lions live is.
Yeah,
South Africa and South Australia.
Both at the bottom of that,
because great whites like you know,
cool is and that's just where you find
them,
so fuck that.
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck that.
Apparently they're finding a lot of them
off the Malibu coast right there.
Seeing them on a regular basis and some
reason north in northern San Francisco,
that area,
they breed out there.
I have a buddy,
my friend Alex Ross who runs a shark
works,
which is actually a porsche,
a man like,
uh,
the,
take Porsche's and modify them and he
calls it.
That's the name of his company.
Shark is a shark fan.
He's a freak.
He told me there's like,
they,
they breed out there,
right?
Like in northern somewhere.
Yeah.
But like what the fuck man.
Like right there,
he's got a damn monster.
That's a good thing to what is called
side.
There aren't that many people swimming
in San Francisco Bay.
There's a video of them taking a
surfboard and pulling it behind a boat
in South Africa just to show there's
this one area that's just overrun with
sharks.
And as they pull this surfboard behind
the boat,
these sharks just,
Pam just hitting the surfboard,
knocking it up in the air.
And you're like,
what?
They're amazing.
Who wouldn't love him?
It's like a lion sale.
Like I love him.
Maybe that girl who lost her arm,
she'd probably wouldn't be really too
much into them.
Did,
did.
Uh,
did you see this,
this petition that they've got just a.
This is from left field,
but it just popped into my head and I
don't know why about the 19 year old kid
who,
um,
who had sex with a 17 year old girl who
had told him when she was 14 and she
told him she was 17 and now he and so he
went to jail and now he's on the sex
offender registry for 25 years and he's
not going to be able to have a career
because he wanted to do software
engineering.
And as part of his parole,
he's not allowed to own a computer.
He's not allowed to own a smartphone
because he's classified as a pedophile.
Even though she was physically mature.
He thought she was 17.
Her parents lobbied the judge and Sheila
with the to plead and say please let
this guy off,
but he,
but instead the judge threw,
threw the book at him basically saying
like,
you should understand that sex is
supposed to be a meaningful and like
holy experience between two people who
love each other.
You shouldn't be hooking up online like
this.
What?
Yeah.
Where was it moralizing?
Uh,
it was in.
Can we check that is either.
It was in the midwest somewhere,
I think Indiana.
So now there's like 150,000
signatures on this petition to try to
get this guy off the sex offender
registry.
You can be on the,
there are people in the sex offender
registry who does urinated in public.
I know again now.
Yeah,
I know a guy did that.
He's a pro pool player.
Apparently that's a story.
At least he went outside and he took a
leak outside of this bar and apparently
it's close to a school and because he's
within x amount of feet of a school he
got,
he got caught by the cops and they,
he's a sex offender for exposing
himself.
Yeah.
Yeah,
like what?
Hear I hear,
here's the stats.
I was looking at this yesterday.
So in six states you can get on the
register if you hire a hooker.
Wow.
In,
uh,
in at least a dozen states already
segregating and hookah,
hookah,
hooker,
it sounds like cheery nestled debbie.
Uh,
and in,
uh,
oh yeah.
Here it is.
To be a monster debate.
Rages over man.
Nineteen.
Put on sex offender registry for 25
years.
Zach Anderson Nineteen.
Met a girl online via hookup APP,
a hot or not last year on the APP.
Girl says she's 17,
however she is actually 14.
Zack traveled 20 miles from Indiana home
to Michigan and slept with her.
He was arrested at the girl's mom.
Became worried about her whereabouts.
Um,
whatever this uh,
this petition is Jamie,
find out where it is and let's give it
out online and fill it out.
Hopefully that's a change.org
thing or something.
I signed it.
I mean,
this poor guy.
He's just a kid,
man.
When you're 19,
first of all,
it's so hard to tell the difference
between a 14 and a 17 year old.
It's so hard.
How do you know there's girls that are
14 that looked like they're 18.
You got to.
We all know that.
Yeah.
Look,
I,
I met a girl who was 25 who looked like
she was fucking 16.
People vary wildly in,
in their appearance and if you're 19 you
don't have a whole lot of experience in
judging that shit.
No,
that's right.
It's not like he fucking got her drunk
or drugged her or any of that like this.
Is that the judge,
first of all,
they should take him and drag him in the
same place.
They dragged that fucking surfboard.
Just take him and feed them to the
sharks.
Dan Savage has been going on a lot about
this status to say because he liked that
guy.
Yeah,
he's great.
He's been on a couple of times and he's.
I mean his.
His point is like,
what the hell?
What
the hell legal rationale is there for
saying that sex is supposed to be this
meaningful thing between two people who
love each other and so you shouldn't be
using hot or not.
Yeah.
It says,
who says the old judge?
And the prosecutor on that job,
the,
when he was getting laid,
there was no hot or not.
He wasn't getting the ladies and we
probably mad that he lost his virginity
at 42 probably fucker.
Yeah.
Or never has maybe switch that robe on
me.
One judge that got caught,
it was had some sort of a masturbation
device underneath the robe.
A condom.
Yeah.
They caught him in the middle of his
proceedings.
She had some like fucking pump on his
dick.
Crazy assholes.
That's great.
I'm wearing one right now.
That's why I'm having such a good time
to.
I don't mind that I.
I welcome that here.
But this guy is a judge.
Okay.
He supposed to follow the law.
We don't want his editorial comment on
the nature of civilization and whether
or not people shouldn't,
shouldn't enjoy sex recreationally.
That's true.
Because that's what he's saying,
that it's got nothing to do with,
with the offense at hand.
I think anytime a judge says something
like that,
you should it like,
fuck you.
You're not a judge anymore because
you've obviously lost your,
your,
your balance.
You've lost your,
your perspective.
That's not what we want from you.
We want for you to be an expert in the
law as it's written in the law,
as it's written,
as opposed to protect people not
protecting anybody here.
Well,
let's try it and the whole point of the
sex offender registry and that kind of
stuff is to protect kids and parents
from predatory,
potentially violent,
repeat child rapists.
Right?
I mean that's ideally what that offender
registry should do.
Hat who,
what kids is it protecting?
Prosecute this 19 year old.
Does anyone seriously believe that if he
has a smart phone at any point in the
next 25 years or whatever it is,
that he's going to be like preying upon
multiple 14 year old girls who look like
this?
17.
Come on.
The whole thing's disgusting.
It's just,
it's just madness that someone thinks
that they could do that.
I have.
I have a theory about that and I've
talked about it on the show before that
I think that one of the main problems
that we have with law enforcement and
with police and even with judge and
prosecutors,
is that it becomes a game.
It becomes a win or lose if the guy gets
off,
you lost.
If the guy,
if you convict him,
you scored and I think we have this
built in thing about playing games and I
saw,
I think it fits very keenly into that
dynamic that we have about winning and
losing and I think that's why cops can
find some sort of a justification for,
for leaving evidence,
for planting evidence.
Like that guy was shot the guy in North
Carolina and drops the Taser and
remember that we shot the guy in the
back and then drops the Taser out his
body.
Like in the POC.
Yeah.
I think there's a lot of that where
it's,
they get locked into this trying to win
thing and some people with cheap,
like people playing pool to like move a
ball when you're not looking to cheat.
Why?
Because they want to win his petty
playing pool.
Yes.
But when you're trying,
when you're a cop,
you also have a
quota.
You know,
I had this guy on Michael Wood who's a
former police officer in Baltimore,
who's enlightening means to how fucked
up Baltimore is.
And how fucked up to police department
is and how crazy it is over there.
But he was like,
you get in trouble if you're not
arresting people,
so if no one commits crimes,
you're fucked.
You're fucked as a cop because they're
like,
that's bullshit.
These people suck.
Like it can't be that it ever.
It ever cleans up.
It can't be like,
hey,
you know what,
I'm Baltimore just became Beverly Hills
and everyone is like this nice old rich
Jewish couple that doesn't do anything
wrong and no one knowing commits crimes.
So we could just,
uh,
relax you like to fire department,
sit around and wait for something to
happen instead of being forced.
Like if the fire department had quotas,
how many fires you put out today,
Wilson,
there was no fire.
They'd be going around fighting fires.
Exactly right.
That's a good point.
Right?
So there's a misalignment of incentives
basically because the people who are
supposed to be doing the cracking down
on crime actually have an incentive for
there still to continue to be some crime
so they can keep doing the cracking down
almost reminds me a little bit of the
military industrial complex where like
the Pentagon,
the Defense Department is supposed to be
about defending us,
but if we don't have wars to go into
then they're kind of redundant.
Exactly.
It's actually good for them when there
is a war ironically.
But you would expect that the people who
are like who are trying to seek our
security would not be one in wars
because wars are bad things.
Yeah.
I think the overall dynamic of how we
operate is flawed fundamentally on so
many different levels that we just sort
of try to patch it up and keep moving.
And I think you could make an analogy
about this hunting thing.
I mean it is kind of fucked that you're
talking about conservation when the best
way to conserve is to get money from
them being murdered.
I mean that,
that's really what you're saying.
The best way is to go over there and
there was an article in huff post
actually today that I was reading and I
was kind of laughing about it because it
was wrong on a lot of different levels
and it was about hunting for
conservation and that this model doesn't
really work or the argument doesn't hold
up and one of the things they brought up
was that $335,000
that that guy had paid to go and shoot
that Rhino and what that Rhino,
what they were saying,
well if this rhinos and danger,
these rhinos are endangered,
yes,
but that rhino was an unviable male.
Like he was old and he wasn't breathing
anymore.
Not only that,
he was killing young male rhinos and
female rhinos and so they had targeted
him for.
They were going to call him.
They were going to kill him anyway.
So the reason why this guy was able to
spend so much money,
shoot this endangered rhino,
it's because they were gonna shoot it
anyway.
And they said,
look,
if we can generate a tremendous amount
of income,
and he.
I had him on the podcast and he said the
amount of money that he paid was
actually small and the reason why it was
small was that all the negative
publicity actually fucked up the
conservation aspect of it because there
are people that would pay half a million
even more for that Rhino.
And they didn't because they were scared
of being having their name thrown into
the pool.
So this cory Knowlton guy went over
there and spent the $335,000,
did everything legally,
and he was in a lot of ways just like
cecil or just like this Walter Hill
guys,
Cecil.
So that.
Then that brings us back to like the
social justice,
like twitter storm thing,
right?
That you're actually,
you're ending up with an inferior
outcome to the outcome that you could
potentially have because the people who
could pull off the best outcome,
so afraid of us old jumping down their
throats on twitter and ruining their
lives,
getting them into a justine sacco.
But then it also gets to like,
Whoa,
is that really the only way you can save
these rhinos?
The only way you can get $335,000
and you have to have someone,
you have to get some guy who wants to
kill one and say,
okay,
you like killing shit,
alright how much some of our docs,
but what else?
Who else is going to pay $350,000
to save rhinos?
I think this is the way if people hate
this idea of hunting for,
for conservation,
if they hate this idea,
the best way to stop it is to really
ramp up conservation as efforts to
really,
really ramp up the idea of non hunting
for conservation and to tell people
like,
look,
we can.
You can generate like Zimbabwe
apparently where this guy was,
they generate some insane amount of
money.
I don't want to quote it because I don't
know if I'm right,
but I read various amounts,
but I think it was like $200,000,000
a year just from hunting just from these
people coming over there to hunt.
And someone said,
well,
that's the only three percent of it goes
to conservation.
That's probably right,
but it's still three percent of
$200,000,000
or whatever the fuck it is.
That's a lot of goddamn money for people
who have nothing over there.
How much could they make from tourism
though,
for people that are looking at the
lions?
That's a good question.
Um,
and that's,
I think maybe the solution in a lot of
these situations.
But also another thing that has to be
carefully considered is that at least in
some areas,
in some places you have to manage
populations of animals because if you
just leave nature onto its own nature
will wipe out animals as well.
Nature doesn't really give a fuck about,
like wolves don't care if they wipe out
all the elk really don't care.
They don't have it in their mind.
They have it in their mind.
What can I kill and eat?
Whether it's dogs or whether it's elk or
whatever.
It can track down and kill.
So you,
the United States has a problem and a
lot of the western states,
because they reintroduced wolves and
they reintroduced wolves and there was a
really interesting video about it,
how wolves are changing yellowstone
national park and they sort of
highlighted the,
the positive aspects of it,
the negative aspects of it or the elk
population are getting decimated because
these elk are not used to wolves because
they didn't develop with wolves and the
wolves are within the last few
generations.
These wolves have been introduced here
and they wanted to keep them within a
certain population.
They wanted to keep them within a few
thousand wools and the whole country.
Well,
they've gone way,
way,
way past that and so now they want to
start hunting these wolves and they do
hunt these wolves in some areas,
but they have all these people that are
freaking out about the hunting of the
wolves.
So you shouldn't hunt these walls,
but you have to.
You don't like you.
You have to manage these populations
because if you don't,
then you have starvation.
Then you have a disease and then you
have them encroaching into livestock.
I have a friend who lives in northern
BC,
British Columbia,
and he is a hunter up there,
and he also has cows.
His neighbor's cow was killed in the
middle of the night by a pack of wolves.
He said,
you don't even know what terror is and
when you're sleeping your house with
your children,
and he said,
you have glass windows that protect you
from the wild,
right?
You're not living in a fortress,
you're living in a normal house and you
look out the window and you see 20,
30,
wild savage,
murderous wolves tearing a cow apart in
front of you screaming and cheering and
ripping this thing apart,
and they'll do that to your kid.
Do that to you.
They'll do that to anything they can get
ahold of.
They don't have morals there.
Their idea is to stay alive.
That is their programming there,
and if you don't manage their
population,
you're fucked.
So in that area,
you can kill as many wives as you want.
Right?
Right,
right.
Where he lives.
I mean,
kill them every day.
It all comes back to this misconception
that people have,
that,
that nature is at a,
at a permanent state of equilibrium,
and the,
we shouldn't tinker with it because
there's some,
some,
something kind of fundamentally precious
about a particular state of,
of nature,
but the reality is almost all states of
nature in the world right now have been
impacted by human civilization already.
So as you say,
like the wolves,
the reason why we have to reintroduce
the wolves because we killed them in the
first place.
And the relationship between the number
of elk in the number of wolves is
already out of whack.
So we need to be able to manage it.
It reminds me a bit.
I was talking to a marine biologist I
think obviously in Tanga will fly specks
South Pacific nation talking to this guy
about whaling.
And I was talking about how opposed I am
to wailing.
I don't think we should be killing
whales.
And he was like,
you know what?
Because we already have killed so many
blue whales and humpback whales will.
The big beautiful wiles,
uh,
the minky whales,
which are the only whales that are
currently being killed by the Japanese
and the Norwegians and so on are
crowding out the,
the bigger wiles from having their
populations being able to come back up.
So it actually,
from a sustainability standpoint,
you may actually want to have some
culling of the minky whales,
which are the sort of little shitty,
the ugly stepchildren of the while of
the whale species because they're eating
all the plankton and they're reading all
the stuff that the blue whales and the
humpback whales could be using to
resurrect their populations.
And in Australia that people go crazy
sometimes,
especially known Australians,
abet,
kangaroo cows,
but you got to kangaroos breed like
rabbits.
They go out there and shoot Kangaroos to
bring down their population so they
don't starve to death sometimes because
have so many of them.
Have a good buddy who's a famous hunter,
Adam Green tree in Australia.
And what he explained to me is what's
really crazy is they brought over
certain animals and when they brought
over certain animals,
then they had to bring over certain
animals to deal with these certain
animals.
And one of the things they brought over
as rabbits and they just fucked up,
man.
They fucked up.
And these are just terrible.
They have so many rabbits that will.
They brought over the pain to the
rabbits.
Yeah,
right.
He said they brought over the foxes to
deal with the rabbits will.
They didn't anticipate as a fox is
killing everything else.
Ground nesting birds.
So they're,
they're,
they're destroying these ground nesting
birds and everything else.
I can get all.
They didn't have a mission.
It's not like they programmed their DNA.
Say,
okay,
you foxes are only attracted to rabbits.
Go kill rabbits and foxes kill
everything.
Cool.
And they also kill a lot of calves.
They kill one of the things that Fox has
left to do and it's a horrible thing.
They,
they can smell and they know when a
mother is about to give birth to a calf.
So they wait until it's coming out.
And they literally pull it out of her
vagina and eat it in front of the
mother.
And that's what they do.
They do that with deer.
They do that with anything they can get
ahold of.
It's just a part of nature.
And they're,
they're having a real problem with that.
The Fox population is just booming.
So they've set up these crazy fences.
They've hired these contractors that
build these enormous fences and
Australia to try to keep the rabbits
out.
The problem is,
it takes a while to build a fence as
they're building the fence,
the rabbits got in and they just fucked
like rabbits inside the fence.
And now the rabbits are over there too.
And they don't know what to do about it.
They're trying to figure out how to
handle it.
It's just,
that reminds me.
So in New Zealand,
I'm half New Zealand,
my mum's a New Zealand,
uh,
and I was just back there a few weeks
ago.
My grandmother passed away.
She was 100.
So like congratulations to her made.
Yep,
that's right.
That mark,
that's the goal,
right?
I mean,
you mentioned being a hundred anyway,
but one of the interesting thing about
New Zealand in terms of all of all of
that conversation around pests is that
it's possibly the only country that
actually has the capability and a major
movement to do so to take itself back to
pre to what the ecosystem was before
humans arrived.
So they like.
I don't know if you know what a key way
is.
The bird,
not the fruit,
short flightless bird that just wanders
around like New Zealand is just lousy
with all of these really,
really evolutionarily dumb animals like
birds that don't fly,
which when approached by a Predator just
stands still in the hope that the
Predator isn't gonna come after them,
which worked prior to the introduction
of western species,
but now that there are boxes and they're
like,
it's not a great survival tactic to just
stand still while the Fox is is coming
after you.
So there's this massive movement in New
Zealand now,
which my uncle is heavily involved in,
in the prime minister is heavily
involved in.
To actually genuinely eradicate all of
these small mammals that were brought in
by by humans when they came.
So it's such a green country.
There's such environmentalist in New
Zealand.
They really,
really get their hands dirty with all
that stuff that's super,
super natural about everything.
But it's funny because in the rest of
the world
if you're an environmentalist you'll
probably an animal lover and you're
probably maybe not a bloodthirsty
person,
but the Kiwis,
the New Zealand is I just so blood test
because they love killing small mammals.
So like it's almost like a part of your
patriotic duty to like just have trap,
settle over the place.
They go out and there's just like a
bloodied old Fox with its head smashed
in by a trap and they're like,
oh good.
We did know we did our job for the
environment today.
It's great.
Well there are hunting magazines in
Australia.
They're really fucking weird because
hunting magazines in America,
they show like a deer or an elk,
like something you hunt for food,
you know,
like,
look,
this guy got an elk bar that's like 500
pounds of meat.
That's awesome.
Well,
hunting magazines in Australia have
those as well,
but they also have guys holding up foxes
and feral cats and my friend gave me a
copy of this magazine and I was like,
do you got fucking dead cats in your
magazine?
Like kitty cats?
Like my cat,
like this is fuck these ones and feral
man.
Yeah,
they're feral.
They didn't make the cut.
They didn't make.
They didn't make the team.
They're out there trying to hustle.
Yeah,
the killing all the birds,
killing all those little flight records
and killing all of the rabbits and
killing all of the.
Anything else I can get ahold of.
New Zealand also has a lot of invasive
large game species.
It's one of the big destinations for
hunting,
like stags stag is a type of elk.
It's like a similar to an l and it's an
enormous,
beautiful,
majestic creature,
but nothing kills them,
but I don't have any big cats over there
like we have in America.
We have mountain lions,
we have bears.
Those all killed the calves.
Like the bears kill more than 50 percent
or as much as 50 percent depending on
who you ask of the Moose that are born,
like as they're coming out.
Same with the Fox.
Do they find the mother as it's giving
birth and they literally killed the calf
immediately.
You need it.
It's one of their favorite things to
eat,
so it keeps the population low.
There's sort of a balance to that,
but they don't have that in New Zealand.
So New Zealand,
they just have these free roaming stags.
They're just massive and they have no
predators,
so it's a huge hunting destination,
so people fly 16 hours to go to New
Zealand.
They have all these animals and you
could bring the meat back so you can
bring back hundreds and hundreds of
pounds of this insanely delicious
stagged meat and it's one of the big
hunting destinations in the world and
you can kind of call it trophy hunting
because everybody wants those antlers as
well.
But the meat is like the best meat in
the world.
It's incredibly delicious and so good
for you.
And so rich nutrients that it doesn't
get like the,
you know,
the,
like shooting lions are.
And also it's not like stags were in
danger and they have to shoot them.
You don't even have to have a license.
That's what's fucked up.
You don't,
you don't have to have tags.
Like in America it's hard to pull a tag
for an elk,
like say like New Mexico.
New Mexico is like prime elk territory.
They have these enormous elk in New
Mexico and they,
it's just a majestic.
And if you can get lucky and get a New
Mexico elk tag for hunters,
like wow,
I'm going to get the milk.
You have to sign up for it.
You get,
it's almost like there's a lottery
and you get picked.
Say like 100 people sign up for tags.
Maybe like 10.
We'll get a tag.
And so you keep trying to get a ticket
to the opening ceremony of the Rio
Olympics or something.
Next year I might have to apply.
And then you've got a one in a thousand
shot up being accepted.
You can probably.
Well,
and also in the same way you could
probably also get a scalper to buy,
sell you a ticket.
You could probably scalp a tag here.
That probably helped me a black market
for them.
I don't even think it's a black market.
I think it's illegal.
Like outfitters get a certain amount of
tags and so that they could sell their
tax for like 25 grand or something.
Exorbitant rate and then do it like
that.
Twenty five grand.
You could fly first class to New
Zealand.
You could screw the tag 16 hours though.
It's a long flight.
You can drive to New Mexico.
You have your own car,
sleeping intent.
My friend from Australia actually came
and hunted in New Mexico.
He flew all the way from New Mexico,
ironically and hunted in,
in new Mac or flew all the way from
Australia,
hunted in New Mexico and wrote this big
story about it.
Cool.
But um,
so it's complicated.
It's speaking of the,
of how good the stags taste.
Like.
I was amazed.
I'm always amazed when I go back to New
Zealand and about how much we're missing
out on great produce in America just
because of the proliferation of,
of industrialized farming and and the,
the dearth of great natural food.
I mean I was,
when I was back in New Zealand,
was staying at this little bed and
breakfast had these eggs for breakfast,
just two fried eggs,
like the yolk was bright red and it
stood up like more than an inch above
the rest of the,
the egg and the white was just perfect.
It was flavor.
Tasted like an egg that I haven't tasted
in years and years.
I was like,
well,
he's come from and she's like,
oh,
what just popped down the road?
We have a few trucks and we just put up
this morning.
They are just fresh from the backyard.
It was like,
that's what an egg.
That's just all I'm doing is eating an
actual leg,
which I haven't.
I haven't had an actual egg in ages.
When are you going back?
Uh Oh.
To New York to New York?
Yeah.
Light on a red eye.
Shit.
Why get some eggs?
I have 22 chickens to get eggs every
day,
man.
I take eggs on the plane.
I don't know if they'll let you.
Well,
it's not coming from another country.
Let me see if I could show you.
I have an image on my instagram of how
incredible the eggs look like.
Jamie,
you see if you could find that,
but yeah,
my eggs or like a dark dark orange.
Beautiful.
And it's because my chickens run around
free.
That's another thing when you see like
vegetarian fed chickens,
like you see that like grass fed
chickens,
you don't want that.
Chickens are fucking dinosaurs.
All right.
They.
They eat everything they eat.
A lot of bugs ate.
I fed my chickens a mouse the other day.
I didn't want to,
but this is a story.
I've already told them,
the podcast,
so I'll.
I'll tell us briefly as possible because
it was very conflicted about this.
I came home,
I was on the road and my family had
found a wounded hawk in our yard and
this goes back to the hierarchy of
animals argument and they found this
wounded hawk or something was wrong with
its wing,
it's broken wing and it was a juvenile
hawk.
It was,
it was,
you know,
conference call but a small.
And so,
uh,
they picked up and put it in a box and
they wanted to feed it and they had to
get it to the veterinarian on Monday,
but they were trying to figure out like
what wildlife organization save these
hawks.
So they said,
well we have to feed this thing,
we have to figure out how to feed it.
So there was a pet store that's open
that sells pinkies,
which are baby mice.
And so they fed this hawk,
these baby mice and it kept it alive
over the weekend and they gave it some
water with an eyedropper.
And then there was one pinky leftover
and my daughter wanted to keep it.
Let's keep,
you have to keep.
I go,
honey,
this is not going to live like it needs
its mothers milk.
The mother's not here,
it doesn't even.
It came.
See it's,
I mean it's only a few days old.
And I was amazed it was still alive and
I said him,
I went,
what are you doing?
Like you were going to do something
about this.
And so the two options were take it to
the pet store and give it back to the
pet store,
which they're going to feed it the
snakes,
that's what they sell them for to sell
them for food or I give it to the
chickens and the chickens to kill it.
Like the hierarchy of animals.
Like you just,
you were just feeding these fucking
things to hawk system.
Like what the hell?
So,
um,
you know,
we made an executive decision and I
decided that I was going to be the one
since I'm the killer,
I go out and feed it to the chicken.
So I opened up the,
there's some of my eggs.
Delicious.
See,
look at the color on the yoke.
The.
Yeah,
like you done.
Just don't get that from the
supermarket.
No,
that Goddamn l you ca tech a hot sauce
to.
I hate that this morning I had some of
those exact same.
That's exactly.
I have that all the time with the
Zucchini bread.
I'll have an egg sandwich.
But um,
so I put the pinky in the chicken.
I have this big huge chicken coop where
they all 22 of them run around.
I mean they have,
it's like,
I don't know how many hundreds of square
feet,
but it's an enormous chicken coop.
And where do you live?
I live out in the burbs.
I live.
I coyotes dear in my yard,
but I put this thing down for a second.
I mean one second.
And these chickens dove on it.
They're murderers,
little fucking dinosaurs.
And they were biting each other's face.
Two steel pieces of this,
this little tiny baby mouse from each
other.
Right.
So goes back to the hierarchy.
And when you,
when you said that birds are dinosaurs
you made,
did you see the story about how the,
how scientists have now I'm sequenced
the genome of woolly mammoths.
Yes.
Which means that within the next 10 or
20 years,
we're going to be able to actually
recreate woolly mammoths and bring them
back.
Should we want to China.
They're going to do it in China just
like they've recreated like Paris and
all these weird city.
You've seen that?
No,
I haven't seen that.
Oh my God.
They have these ghost towns in China
where they've recreated famous European
cities and no one's living in them.
They don't know what the fuck they're
doing.
Or like an Eiffel Tower in China.
They have everything.
They.
It's so bizarre.
I look at this like these.
These are.
This is a real recreated city in China
and they're ghost towns.
There's no one living in them.
I mean,
I did know about the ghost towns,
but I didn't know that they will
replicated off other existing cities.
China's replica of Paris.
Go to that page,
Jamie,
because it's fucking insane and there's
lot of people that aren't aware of that.
It's an entirely depressing ghost town.
That is an exact replica of Paris.
Go to full screen if you would in the
apartments look like perusing and upon
their exact.
The exact,
it's insane.
And look at the Eiffel Tower,
you can see like a that they were like
just regular skyscrapers in like a
neighboring city.
Yeah,
it's really,
really,
really strange and they haven't just
done it with Paris but like this is,
this is abandoned,
this is what's really fucked about it.
Why they have been in the of people
moving into.
I don't think it worked.
They had an idea to build something and
have a bunch of people move in,
but.
And everybody's like,
what?
The Chinese government,
they just forced people to live there.
I think they're just sort of slowly but
surely becoming more capitalistic.
Yeah,
but they're no less authoritarian.
They're having a big crackdown in China.
It's much more authoritarian than it's
been in the past couple of decades in
terms of like anti free speech and just
forcing people to do whatever the
whatever Beijing wants them to.
Right.
You're right.
But capitalism as far as their ability
to earn money and that's the apparently
a huge issue that's in China now is the
haves and the have nots and how baller
everybody wants to act and behave and
it's become a huge part of their culture
like flossing and having the finest of
everything to find his bag and the
finest watch and the fines.
If you're,
if you're a CEO of a company,
you must have a home that is bigger and
more grand than anyone working for you
or the other competitive companies that
are,
you know,
other also have ceos.
You have to have the biggest.
Okay.
Oh,
it's incredibly consumerist.
China and I read an interesting piece
about how different Asian cultures spend
their money and one of the points was
that Chinese,
Japanese people,
Japanese and Chinese culture is like
totally different.
Japanese in Japan,
people when people earn money,
they will usually put it towards making
the home as nice as possible so that you
go into a Japanese home and it's
beautiful.
Outwardly.
People aren't so obsessed with like
flashy things in China.
People will live in an absolute shit
hole if it means that they can afford
like the best watch or the best car or
like the best handbag.
So there's like a lot more kind of
outward consumerist,
almost like you say,
capitalist style,
con consumption conspicuous consumption
rather than just sort of feathering
their nest the way that the Japanese
home bodies too.
What was interesting,
it's like a repression thing,
like a response to oppression,
sort of like Catholic school girls,
Catholic school girls,
you know,
everybody knows I grew up,
I,
I dated a girl that was in Catholic
school when I was,
uh,
in high school and she was a freak.
She was just such a freak.
And it was because everything was like,
you're going to Howl,
sex is bad and you get that girl alone.
And she was just bought bananas just
bonkers.
Yeah.
I think that's what happens with the
repression,
you know,
some preacher's daughter type shit.
Well,
they're also coming from a much lower
also coming from a much lower place.
So if,
you know,
if dirt poor,
and if you've just had a,
you know,
the past couple of decades,
be your big boom,
and then I suppose you want to show that
you're profiting from it more than a
country like Japan,
which has basically been rich since the
sixties.
Yeah.
They like a hybrid of like a communist
and a capitalist state right now there's
sort of like,
well they're not,
I don't think it's fair to call them
capitalists because it's best capitalism
should be about the free exchange about
entrepreneurism.
Right?
And the ability of individual human
beings to start their own businesses and
to trade with one another that is still
not the way that the Chinese economy
runs.
But I think what you're alluding to is
the fact that they are rapaciously pro
money and desperate to,
you know,
to enhance their,
their economic growth as quickly as
possible.
So it's not like they're,
you know,
Mousey tongue said,
uh,
you know,
when someone,
someone said that the reforms that he
was bringing in,
or maybe it was Deng Xiaoping said that
the reforms that he was bringing in,
what kind of capitalist,
uh,
and shouldn't he have more of an
allegiance to communism?
He said,
you know,
black cat white cat,
as long as it catches mice.
Ooh,
clever bastard.
Not always so good at things.
They're so good at saying,
you know,
like Sun Tzu's art of war.
You read that shit today.
Like,
damn at that dude nailed it.
Right.
So you know,
they want to make money.
They don't give him no,
don't give a toss whether you call it
capitalism will come from.
I think you might describe it as a kind
of.
It's almost like a 19th century
mercantilist like regime.
It's almost like the British empire was
or something where there's,
there wasn't a lot of freedom for
individuals to,
to prosper off their own bat.
And there were a lot,
there wasn't a lot of free industries.
So you would have like big state
supporting industries that,
for example,
ran like cartels,
you know,
only one company was allowed to import
cotton into Britain or something like
that and that you,
these cozy relationships between mega
conglomerates and politicians and the
government.
I mean that's Kinda what it's like in
China.
So it used to be that you got a signed
an occupation saying the way that we
think of Russia or the way that we think
of Cuba that they tell you,
hey,
this is what you're going to do and so
you go do this and you get paid x amount
by the state and that's all you get.
But that wasn't good for business.
Like you got to give people an incentive
in order to push harder and to innovate
and like you got to,
they have to know that that juicy watch
is like dangling from that string,
like a carrot in front of them.
That's what makes them push and that's
where they fucked up.
And that's where they sort of see.
They'd see that about America.
Like look,
these dummies work all day for Alexis.
They just want that car.
So bad and they see that billboard as
they're driving home in their fucking
shitty Hyundai.
Not that Honda is are Shitty by the way.
I like that actually.
Really Nice.
Now I was in one this weekend in Brazil
and I was like,
these things are like fucking Mercedes
now.
You know what I.
I'm driving a Kia here.
I always thought of kids as being like
crappy.
It's fantastic.
No,
not bound anymore.
I got an upgrade like at the Avis Guy
gave me an upgrade on
it because I'm some elite thing or
something or some credit card or
whatever that I've got and he was like,
oh,
I have a gray Kia.
I'm like,
what?
Are you kidding me?
You upgraded me to a key.
I'll.
Thanks a lot buddy.
Some upgrade me to the worst car in the
world.
No,
it's great.
Well,
this is the golden age of automotive
engineering.
All cars are show that they've learned
so many lessons from the past few
decades at all cars that the United
States used to be known for having Shit
cars like we used to make shitty fucking
cars.
We made really cool looking cars in the
sixties and then for 20 years we just
shit all over the,
the people that were buying cars and you
had to be like a martyr to buy an
American car.
Like a Japanese car was cheaper.
It was better engineered.
It would break down less and for most of
automotive history you're talking about
like starting in the eighties or
something?
I think it was the seventies from the
seventies on when the gas crisis hit in
the 19 set,
I believe it was like 73,
74 American muscle cars and American
like big cars,
like the cadillacs,
the things that people really loved
about American cars,
those signified America.
You know,
when you thought about automobiles,
you thought about those big cadillacs,
they'll show a smooth,
cushy rides.
No one was making those in Germany knows
and making those,
that was a true American product,
but then gas became insanely expensive
and once the gas crisis hit America
started making four cylinder mustangs.
That looked like shit and everything
just fell apart and they've.
They were really unreliable.
Then there was also the issues with
unions.
The issues with automotive unions,
the union workers wanted to get paid a
fuck load of money and I had a buddy who
was a union employee in Detroit and he
told me like how they used to do it and
it was just ridiculous.
The,
the,
the demands the unions had and what they
were able to achieve in bargaining.
They would have a job that one person
could do easily eight hour day job,
but two people would take that job.
There was,
it had to be a two person job.
The union demanded it,
so what they would do is one guy would
show up for four hours a day and then he
would leave.
The other guy would show up four hours a
day.
So you had both punch in,
you know,
but one guy would like punch in at 9:00
and he would go fuck off for four hours
and then he'd go back and the other guy
would relieve him and you know,
they would just switch off like that.
And the company car companies would have
these massive long term liabilities,
right?
Because then have like pension programs
that were defined benefit pensions
instead of defined input pinch out and
that might not be the correct economic
way of saying it,
but like instead of you put into your
pension and then when you retire at you
get back what you put in.
It's we will pay you x amount for the
rest of your life.
Like a form of social security.
I mean it's even more weird than social
security.
It's like a form of guaranteed corporate
welfare for all of the unionized
employees for the rest of their lives.
After they retire.
Yeah.
Ends a lot for a company to be able to
bear and that's why they moved all their
things overseas.
I mean that's what happened when they
started just shipping everything
overseas and then ironically Japanese
companies started shipping their things
to America.
Like a lot of Honda's are built in
America,
like different Japanese companies.
I don't know how the fuck it works now.
One of the biggest Mitsubishi Plants in,
in the Asia Pacific was in Australia.
Like why?
Why are they building it and doing it in
Australia and I don't know.
They must have got some sort of a deal.
I don't know how it works.
And then South Korea came online and
started making good cause like the key
is now.
Right.
The Honda is,
are fantastic.
They're,
they're luxury one that they make that
one that looks like a Mercedes.
They sort of ripped off Mercedes design.
Yeah.
What's that creek twice or.
No,
that's not it.
What is it not on the Elantra?
Is Genesis equus or something like that?
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean,
but I've,
I've heard you talk also about like the,
the muscle cars of the fifties in terms
of like the,
that still in Cuba and still working and
running.
Right.
I went to Cuba or was it this past new
year's?
No,
like two a year and a half ago.
And Man,
it's just incredible seeing like
cruising around Havana.
Ollie's old.
Cool.
They love those cars.
They're still going tanks they call
them.
Yeah.
They call them Yank tanks because they
built these enormous metal fucking
buildings that you could drive around
and those was 55 Chevy's and things
along those lines.
Do you think,
was that while I was going to say,
do you think that the American industry
is ever going to be as innovative as it
was back in the fifties and it's never
going to rule the coop?
Um,
it's gonna be real tough to rule the
coop,
but they've made an insane comeback.
The new American cars are incredible.
I drove one of those Cadillac escalades.
That thing is a marvel of engineering.
The entire screen,
the entire dashboard is an LCD screen,
huge lcd screen that controls the
dashboard lcd screen that controls the
navigation.
Everything is magnetic ride control.
So you go over bumps and it's like
butter,
incredible engineering.
Like the car is beautiful.
They ride gray.
It's an enormous car,
but it rides like a small car.
Like when you drive one of those big
cadillac escalades,
that thing feels like you're driving
like a mid sized car.
That's.
This is what it looks like inside.
Gorgeous.
They take,
they took it up a 100 notches.
I mean it's an amazing car.
I almost bought one.
I can't remember close,
but I went with the instead because
lexus is a.
They go,
uh,
they're,
they're based off of the Land Cruiser
and the land cruisers.
One of the best platforms for driving
off road.
They actually have a lift.
He press a button,
it lifts the car up.
So it gives you more ground clearance on
the lexus or the linkers.
Lexis is the same car as a Land Cruiser.
Amazing Lexus ls five 75 70.
Yeah.
Is this same exact car as the Toyota
Land Cruiser?
It's just they,
it's like they call it a Land Cruiser
and drag.
They just make it a little more fluffy
on the inside and modal,
prettier on the outside.
But I'm an idiot and for some reason I'm
like,
well,
what if the apocalypse happens?
I don't have to drive on the dirt.
Aren't neutral department car like a
drop in the dirt.
I'm one of those dummies and things I
need to cash canister in my car.
No fuckin grass.
You'll be laughing on the other side of
your face when that,
when that happens,
when it all goes to shit.
Now when it all to shit,
if a meteor hits,
I hope it hits me in the head.
I hope the meteor hits my house and I
hope you don't even know about it.
I don't want.
What's that whistling sound?
Boom.
But I don't want to be that guy.
That's like the.
Like the prepper.
That's right.
Right.
You know when you're fucking hold up
trying to take little cat naps while
you're holding a shotgun because you're
worried that someone's going to come and
steal your canned peaches.
I don't want to be that guy.
But then I also don't want to be
completely unprepared.
Like I don't even have an emergency.
I live in Manhattan and I don't even
have a little bag with some like granola
bars in it and some fresh water in case
we get hit with a dirty bomb or
something.
You know that stuff.
I have that stuff I have.
I have freeze dried food.
I have hundreds of pounds of frozen meat
because I hunt.
So I have like,
if I can keep some sort of power on,
you know,
like by generator or solar,
I have food for a long time,
but that's not why I do it.
I do it because that's what I actually
do eat really prepping for doomsday in
terms of those that,
those cars being so sophisticated
nowadays.
I was interviewing a guy from,
I think it was Gorka who was involved in
um,
in a,
like a test where these hackers
encouraged him to get in the car I
think.
Right.
And then they,
they hacked into the,
like the was,
it was recent,
right.
Really when they shut it off.
So they yet now they've turned it off
the side of the road.
That's right.
So you could have like,
imagine if you have hundreds of
thousands of a particular type of car
driving around in America and because
they're all wifi enabled and they're all
saddled,
they've got,
they're all on the satellite and
everything.
You can have hackers or terrorists or
just knit a wells or some kind of hack
in.
And theoretically,
I mean they can certainly slow down the
car.
They can certainly make the cotton,
they can certainly screw around with it
in some way,
but if they could make it speed up to
160 miles an hour and then via sharply
to the right,
you could be killed 100,000
people like that.
Like that.
Well,
that's the argument for Michael
Hastings.
You know that story,
right?
Remind me,
Michael Hastings was the journalist that
was writing all these stories about
generals like he had taken down.
He was one of the guys that had taken
down to and mcchrystal mcchrystal pace.
Find out about it.
Um,
I remember his name.
Yeah.
Michael Hastings.
Well,
his car,
he had actually,
was it,
was that taken down crystal?
Yeah,
yeah.
He did the mcchrystal,
right.
That's right.
So he did that and he was insanely
worried about his safety.
Yeah.
And he was telling people like,
look,
if I wind up dead,
I didn't kill myself,
just know this.
Well,
he died because his Mercedes was
barreling down sunset going into 120
miles an hour running a tree.
I remember they were like,
he committed suicide and not only that,
the engine flew from the wreckage.
I'm like,
there is right there.
That's a,
that's the video of the car,
and these cars today are so fucking
computer.
There's so
much gadgetry and stuff going on inside
of them that there are many that argue
that not only it has been possible for a
long time,
but they've been doing this for a long
time.
He was a good guy.
He was a good report.
I have is with buzzfeed.
Um,
well there's a lot of people that
believe he was murdered.
Yup.
There's a pace.
I've got a place here in New York
magazine,
which I just chatted to Jamie,
who killed Michael Hastings,
reflexively distrustful Egan to make
powerful enemies.
The young journalist who's Mercedes
exploded in Los Angeles one night,
couldn't possibly have died
accidentally.
There's a lot of people that believe
that,
that will also.
He had apparently he had crystal
methodist system.
But here's the thing.
A lot of people that work really hard
and that do long hours and are involved
in journalism,
they take adderall.
Okay.
And adderall and crystal meth or fucking
kissing cousins.
They're almost exactly the same.
I'm not saying that he wasn't really on
crystal meth and I don't know.
I don't.
I didn't look at the toxicology
examination,
but they could've been lying about it
and just.
It could have been adderall.
Adderall is so fucking common.
There's so many people that take that
shit,
especially people that are on deadlines
and they need energy to push through
something pretty common in journalism.
And so the idea is,
oh,
he went back on the drugs,
he was on adderall and he drove into a
tree man or math and drove into a
treatment and not.
Not necessarily who knows?
Who knows,
but in speaking of adderall,
did you see the story this week that the
electronic game is association is going
to start drug testing as a game is going
to be drug tested for.
I mean I interviewed the DS.
Yeah.
For,
for PDS,
like adderall and I mean I did.
I had a conversation on huff post live
with the head of the,
of the.
Of that.
What does it do?
The Electronic Gaming Association.
It's something that the Srb I think.
Yeah.
So I had the,
like the president of that on,
oh,
whatever.
And a bunch of gamers and like some
sports psychologists and sort of
ethicists about this and like,
it's so weird why we object to doping in
the first place.
Like it gets very complicated.
Like I understand.
Oh yeah.
Protocol on adderall,
right?
That's right.
So that's what sparked this whole thing
because he made those comments.
So then they're like,
oh,
we got to crack down on it.
Well that's like cracking down on comics
for marijuana if they start drug testing
comedy clubs,
good fucking luck.
Uh,
you know what Greg Fitzsimmons said last
night on my app,
my wonderful podcasts that everyone
should listen to,
they all cheapy live.
What does it WTP live and isn't there an
underscore and somewhere handle WTP,
undisclosed live on twitter?
Who has WTP live on twitter?
That's a good point.
What the fuck?
Some asshole who I'm going to have to be
novel possible.
Somebody else has that.
Exactly.
Why would they?
I don't know what it is.
So many ways with people and if you want
to get on our mailing list,
you can email info@wtplive.com
and what it was greg saying,
Greg,
Greg Timmins,
my buddy greg.
Greg Fitzsimmons was a was saying now
I've forgotten what he said.
Well,
we're just talking about about adderall.
Adderall,
comedy clubs pot.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
He was saying like if you,
if you were going to,
we want to take Lance Armstrong's medals
away.
He was like,
if you took away every award
or prize that you give to people for
something that they did while they were
on drugs and there would be no grammys.
It's true.
Right?
That's true.
Well,
Bill Hicks had that great joke about it.
You know,
you know that I'm about drugs,
about every,
you know,
if you want to stop drugs,
like take all your albums and throw them
away.
If you hate drugs.
All those great songs and led Zeppelin,
the doors,
all that shit.
They were on drugs.
They're on drugs.
What do you think about about doping?
Cause I think like so.
All Right Lance,
glad you brought this up because Jeff
Novitsky who busted Lance Armstrong is
going to be on my podcast.
He was hired by the ultimate fighting
championship.
The UFC is trying to clear up the sport
and they're trying to clean it up by
hiring the most knowledgeable anti
doping guy ever.
The guy who busted the ball co scandal
and Lance Armstrong and all that stuff.
I had the most fascinating conversation
with him in Brazil.
We were at a bar and we were talking for
over an hour about all the different
methods that they're using now to get
away with.
That's my man.
Great Guy.
Really enjoy talking to him and he'll be
on soon and really empathetic and
sympathetic guy and you know,
he's not like some evil person is just
like some fucking Jack Law here to take
down the criminals.
He's uh,
he's the guy who was sort of seeing both
sides of it and that's one of the way,
one of the reasons why the people
cooperated with him to kind of go after
Lance Armstrong.
Yeah.
So people will say like,
all right,
well lance,
you know,
that was the reason why it's bet what
Lance Armstrong did is bad is because
it's on a fair.
Well,
Lebron James is.
Genetics is unfair,
right?
I mean the fact that I now feel better
after having two cups of coffee then I
did an hour ago is unfair be too.
Yeah,
I mean I'm jet lagged and Shit,
but I have a two cups of coffee and for
Alpha brands and I'm kicking right in.
How different is that stuff from
adderall?
I mean,
isn't it all just degrees?
Like maybe we should just a lamp.
Why maybe we should just allowed doping?
Um,
I think to a certain extent,
I think one of the real problems with
Lance Armstrong said he was suing people
that we're accurately talking about his
drug use because they got busted and he
was going after them and trying to ruin
them.
He's a,
an absolutely and a liar at just a
pathological liar,
deceiver.
But that's.
But that's less interesting I think.
Then the question of like whether or not
the laws that he broke should be against
the rules that he broke should be
against the rules in the first place,
but I agree with that and also there's
also an argument that the Tour de
France,
notice how I said France and that was
very impressed.
I'm very,
very good at the misspelling ties with
the one they say that that race is so
grueling.
There's an argument that it's actually
healthier to do with drugs.
That doing it with drugs actually allows
your body to recuperate in a way that
you would be breaking it down and you
would be susceptible to rhabdomyolysis.
You know?
That's that thing that those crossfit
people get.
Start pissing looks like diet coke,
you know?
Have you ever seen it?
No,
I don't.
Oh my God.
It's awful.
When when people have a breakdown of
their muscle tissue and then your,
your,
your body starts processing it and it
comes out in your urine.
Like ultra marathon runners have it.
I have a buddy who runs ultra marathons
and he says,
when you done you pee,
it's black like soda or like coffee,
it's awful and it's just your body's
just,
your kidneys are malfunctioning.
Everything's just shutting down.
Not The fittest guy in the world,
but uh,
and I'm not proud of that.
Are you sure?
I am not the fittest guy in the
wheelchair and tested yourself.
I have not tested myself.
I could be.
That's a very good point Mike,
be.
But I think if you're doing as string
and all,
if you're running marathons,
good for you,
good for you America.
But if you pissing black,
your body's telling you that you
shouldn't be doing that.
Well,
what they're doing is they're just
trying to push past all the pain and
discomfort and show mental toughness.
And that's what's supposed to be
inspiring is that,
you know,
this guy ran like my buddy,
uh,
Cameron Hanes,
he ran 106 miles in 24 hours,
does a 24 hour race where you had a one
mile course and he did it a hundred and
six times in 24 hours.
He and he came in fourth place,
didn't even fucking win.
Some dude ran like 120 something miles.
This is insane.
And he said it's crazy.
How can you combine them all?
I don't know,
animals that's like,
I mean,
they got beat by a chick too.
I think a chick came in third place.
Well,
she's definitely on the juice.
You never know.
Uh,
I mean just being angry,
you know,
running on the fuel of eight,
they're almost equivalent of 50 iron man
triathlons in 50 days in 50 states to
promote fitness among youth.
Oh my God.
But is that fitness is.
I mean,
are you actually doing good for
yourself?
If you know 50 triathlons in 50 days?
Well his body has the capacity to do
that kind of work and my body doesn't.
So the argument is,
and he's getting more fit,
you're better than me,
is the argument is that his body is more
fit than the average person's body,
but he's definitely not doing a service.
Like my friend who did it,
Cameron,
he did it a couple months ago and he
said he hasn't recovered yet,
so he's still hasn't recovered.
He said when he runs,
like he still runs,
but when he runs he's like,
you still feeling that he's not back to
baseline to where he was.
His times were off.
He's,
he's exhausted and he didn't even come
first.
No second.
His legs,
his legs swelled up.
He said almost twice the size they
normally are.
Yeah.
Fuck all that.
I'm happy here.
I'm going to open a BA pretty soon.
We got whiskey,
man.
We can just go hard right now.
Let's spark up a joint and have a drink.
I would definitely have it be.
I think you want a beer?
Yeah.
Beer.
That'd be one.
A couple of beers.
Great.
Look,
it's five.
10.
I'm Australian.
If as soon as the clock ticks five.
Every Australian has to stop drinking.
Yeah,
I'll have us there too as well.
That sounds good.
It's the law.
We've got a few good ones.
We've got that.
Uh,
what does that butte like a dark beer.
Black Butte port.
Yeah.
I love that stuff.
Um,
I,
yeah,
I think it's a real good argument
that coffee is a stimulant and that
stimulant helps and if that helps why
not adderall.
And also marijuana allows you to see
things in a different way and if you can
do that and maybe write something
better,
marijuana helped you write that thing.
That's not exactly just your creativity.
It's also the marijuana.
Yeah,
and the weird thing is when there are
drugs that are not actually performance
enhancing but are also banned,
like marijuana will be banned in
sportswear.
It clearly wouldn't actually give you an
advantage,
but like which ones I don't have any
kind of athletic sport is probably not
going to be enhanced by meryl
and it was actually what you're wrong.
They're actually showing,
especially ultra marathon runners,
they're showing that marijuana does have
a significant impact on ultra marathon
runners,
not just about coordination sports.
What about,
you know,
playing soccer or something and put them
out sweet.
Better
too.
That's where it's crazy.
No,
would you?
Jitsu is a big one.
Jujitsu.
It's really,
really,
really common for Jujitsu guys to train
on marijuana.
A matter of fact,
I'm better at Jujitsu when I do
marijuana than I am when I'm sober.
How high can I still be bad?
High as fuck.
Really high as fuck to the point where I
can't even demonstrate techniques.
Like I try to forget.
I forget how it works or didn't work.
See,
I'm uh,
when I,
when you're in it.
See when you're sparring.
The idea about sparring is okay,
we've got this stuff.
This is from New Mexico.
This
really good.
You can take it.
Yeah,
I'll try the new one because I know in
new castle and I know.
So I'll try.
Thanks Jamie.
Um,
but
the idea is that it allows you to get to
this sort of zen state where you flow.
So the things you already know,
they think it's not that good for the
learning stuff,
but it's actually.
I'll thank you sir.
What a gentleman.
He opens his,
he opens one and hands it to me and then
he gets his own.
What a good man.
I do what I was raised,
right joe?
You were sir.
You were.
The idea is that it's not good at
learning stuff because it just goes in
and out,
but the stuff that you already know
that's in your system that you already
have trained down,
you know,
it's like a part of your.
So it's almost muscle memory in a way
that doesn't require a lot of cognitive
effort.
Yeah,
like tennis players,
apparently fine marijuana helps them
significantly as well.
Recreational tennis players would tell
you when they get really high,
they kind of like see the ball better.
They can move pool players.
It's a huge thing with pool with people
you can feel where the ball's going
better.
The guys who play,
they say it gives them like a 10,
20 percent advantage when they,
when they smell it.
I think there are different types of
people who respond to the drug
differently of course,
because I mean,
I,
I'm not a huge pot smoker.
I'll have it occasionally.
Uh,
I can only have like a very small amount
just so I get that buzz.
If I have too much,
I start to get scattered and like
paranoid and just like I can't focus,
I can't do things.
I kind of can be creative.
I can't follow the plot of like
television shows and stuff it.
Whereas I know I've got tons of friends
who are like,
well that's not me.
Yeah,
well they probably swung a lot of pot
to.
Yeah,
that's probably true.
The tolerance thing that's real and also
the acceptance of the experience.
I think when you fight the experience
like Oh high and that's where paranoia
comes in.
And also I think paranoia is also one of
the things that does is it
lowers the boundaries that we put up in
order to get things done.
Like we have boundaries.
Like there's a sort of blinders that you
put on that allow you to get through
your job and get in your car and drive
home to your family and not consider the
massive amount of variables at the world
creates or that the world presents and
also space.
The fact that you're on a fucking giant,
24,000
mile round ball that's going a thousand
miles an hour in a circle and hurling
through infinity when he smoked pot,
it sort of unveils all of these
possibilities and potentials and it
freaks people out.
Well,
I don't get freaked out by that.
I mean,
what you're describing,
you're not taking enough,
but that said,
well,
maybe you will.
Maybe I just needed a better dealer or
something.
Yeah,
sure.
I don't want to take it on the plane,
the uh,
but,
um,
smell this and we'll get you high.
Are you,
are you allowed to have this as this
medicinal last patient I have.
Wow.
That smells great.
Beautiful flowers.
What your,
what you're talking about there in terms
of the doors of perception being kind of
shut down.
Yeah.
During normal behavior strikes me as
more of a psychedelic thing.
I mean,
I've had some of the most in like
insightful experiences of my entire
life.
I don't do them anymore,
but when I was in my late teens and
early twenties doing acid or mushrooms
and having that sense of sudden complete
awareness that you are on a rock that's
going around this star on the outer edge
of a spiral galaxy in a cosmos that is
so vast that you,
you cannot comprehend it and we have
evolved as a species to not comprehend
it and to not focus on it all the time
because if we actually thought about
where we are and what we're doing and
how many things could be thrown at us at
any point in,
in time,
we'd go crazy.
You wouldn't even bother like aiding.
You wouldn't buy like working and eating
anymore because everything would seem
so,
so kind of trivial.
Yeah.
Does to many people.
I have a lot of friends in the quote
unquote psychedelic community that lived
their lives around the time they do
psychedelics and then the downtime in
between.
There were the sort of processing it and
gearing up for their next psychedelic
trip and for them it's just that's their
life.
That's a part of their life.
Like those,
those crazy trips and those realizations
that is a significant part of their
existence and what's make makes life
wonderful to them.
And then there's people like you that
say,
Hey,
I did it before,
I don't do it anymore.
Yeah.
Well I mean I wonder if there are also
like non drug related ways of getting
there.
Like I,
I know this guy got out or a pendant
Dusa who's a,
a Hindu chaplain.
He's the first Hindu chaplain of a
Columbia University and yeah.
So he
hinduism as a religion.
But a chaplain.
Yeah.
Which I guess is the religious authority
at the university.
Okay.
So it's a designation by the.
The university.
Yeah,
but he's just a Hindu spiritual teacher
in New York.
Lovely guy.
And he is just know you can.
It's like the Dalai Lama or something.
Right.
You can just sense this awareness of
like him just being on another plane.
He is not bothered by the same trivial
stuff that distracts us.
He is clearly communing with some kind
of level of existence that is beyond the
material.
And I think that that is sort of similar
to the mindset that you can get into
with psychedelics.
Well,
I think yoga can take you there if you
do the right kind of yoga.
I do hot yoga,
like a [inaudible] type hot yoga and
it's great for the body.
It was really is great for relaxation.
Like to me,
my on some things happening.
Like when I do a lot of yoga I was
talking about,
I got in a car accident,
somebody rear ended my expensive Germans
porche car and I,
I,
you know,
I asked are you okay?
Everything okay.
And I wasn't even mad at him,
you know,
I should've been probably upset that
this guy wasn't paying attention or
texting or whatever the fuck it was and
slammed into my car and cost me a
shitload of money.
But I wasn't.
And I attribute it to doing a lot of
yoga that week.
I think it calms you down.
I think there's something.
I mean there's a reason why those skinny
Indian dudes have been doing that shit
for thousands of years.
I don't think they'd just been.
It's just like a hobby.
And they just stuck with it,
but Kundalini Yoga,
which I don't practice,
but I have friends that do and I have a
friend who teaches it in boulder and
she's,
uh,
a firm advocate of achieving psychedelic
states through this practice.
You get up at 4:00
in the morning and you do these
breathing exercises and you want to sit
in a certain direction and it's all like
very ritualistic,
but it's also based on the idea of the
circadian cycle.
You sort of interrupt your sleep cycle
and the cycle of the earth and you,
you do these stimulation exercises that
supposedly a activate your pineal gland,
which is the gland that's been proven to
produce dimethyltryptamine,
which is the most potent psychedelic
drug known to man.
And it's related in many ways to
psychedelic mushrooms.
They're very similar in their chemical
composition.
And we know that,
you know,
these,
these psychedelic drugs that the brain
produces.
If you can take them and you extract
them from plants and every,
the existence,
thousands of plants.
You have these insanely profound
visionary experiences.
She says that you can achieve these
states through meditation and through
Kundalini Yoga.
I don't doubt that I don't get out or a
bill,
you know,
he meditates two or three hours a day.
That would probably explain why he is
the type of person that he is.
And you get into weird places when you
do that.
Well,
I do a,
I do a lot of meditation in an isolation
tank.
I have an isolation to wanting to do.
Dude.
I can hook it up and tell me when you
tell me when I'll look it up.
Like,
well,
I'm not here.
I was so connected to this,
this,
this community community.
Yep.
Put me in touch with someone in New York
City.
Had a good good.
There must be good.
Outfit out
the word right now and we will get
messages on twitter.
I guarantee you there's places in New
York.
When I started talking about this about
10 years ago,
a little bit more,
maybe like 2002.
Um,
there were very few of these.
Now they're all over the country and
me making videos and talking about it.
I've had one in my basement when I first
started talking about it,
the float lab,
where I got mine from,
which is in Venice,
which is the finest float tanks in the
world next to this guy in Austin.
I was also has amazing one,
but they were basically like almost on
the verge of going out of business.
Now they're opening up new locations,
new locations all over the country,
all over the world.
In fact,
a lot of them they have as their option,
like how did you learn about this?
Joe Rogan is like one of the options
because I talk about it so much.
That's great.
I just,
I just think it should be something that
everybody should do.
I think it's.
It's an amazing form of meditation.
It's amazing relaxation for your body.
It's an incredible way for your body to
get magnesium because it absorbs it
through the,
through the skin,
the epsom salts.
It's one of the best ways that your body
can absorb magnesium and it's a hugely
important for muscle recovery and for
your health and wellness and relaxation.
It's an incredible experience.
All right.
You heard it here.
If you look,
if you are a float tank person,
I'm going to New York.
We're gonna.
Hook it up 100 percent.
I'm going to put out the word.
Awesome.
We'll put it out on twitter.
Bam.
Yeah,
that's my tank.
Yeah.
That's the video that we made.
A huge.
Yeah,
they use me.
Yeah.
Oh,
there we go.
That's perfect.
I don't even know these people.
That's New York.
Okay.
There you go.
Great.
Okay,
so New York aspire.com
flotation.
Hey,
how about you reach out to my buddy josh
steps and hook them up.
If you listen to,
we reach out to me,
send an email to info@wtplive.com
and I could use a little posts about
stockers are going to say,
yeah,
this is the place,
if they're going to give you the
address,
but fortunately said who will go through
that?
It's going to be plastic all over the
floor and it goes some fucking dexter
house.
Uh,
when we were talking about the size of
the cosmos and how mindblowing all of
that is,
it reminded me,
did you see about this Russian
billionaire who has just invested
$100,000,000?
Yeah.
Not,
not to talk,
to listen,
to listen in.
He just needs mushrooms.
You can meet aliens in an hour,
an hour and 20 minutes so you could be
there.
So he's got like Stephen Hawking and all
these amazing people on board to.
It's the biggest injection of cash to
the,
of the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence in history.
I think a guy like hockings just like,
okay,
look,
if you want to throw some money at
science,
you know,
I mean,
that's really what it is.
It's just science.
I mean,
if you want innovation,
you want to.
I mean,
it's great.
It's a great thing.
I personally think that there's,
there's two very distinct possibilities.
What,
I mean there's many,
but there's two that I consider all the
time.
One of them is that this is it,
that what we have achieved is
exceedingly rare,
incredibly rare.
And that if the universe is 13 point 7
billion years old or whatever the fuck
it is when it started,
then it's entirely possible that it took
this long for something to come out of
it like us and that we are at the front
of the line of the idea of conscious
life where the only thing that we know
of on this whole planet that's not just
conscious but conscious and manipulates
its environment to the point where we
can change the weather.
We can do all
kinds of crazy shit.
Like send videos all to Australia
instantaneously.
If you're in Australia and I'm here,
you can send me a text message with a
photograph of you smiling and I'll get
it in a couple of seconds.
Oh,
we could be having the same conversation
we're having right now.
Yeah.
Really,
really clearly.
And that's just madness.
That's madness.
I think it is entirely possible that we
are as advanced as intelligent life has
ever gotten ever in the entire universe.
And that all of our searching and
longing is really just some Alpha
chimpanzee thing where we're always
looking for the daddy.
You know,
it might be a god or it might be a king
or it might be a guru or something.
We're always looking for someone to show
us the way because we know we don't know
the way
it's possible.
It's entirely possible that that's the
case.
Um,
and you're right,
that life got started here pretty much
as quickly as it could and it evolved
into our sort of level of consciousness
as quickly as you would expect it to
given natural selection.
So it's true that we could be at the
beginning,
you know,
we could be sort of the,
the,
the first intelligent conscious species
in the cosmos,
but the fact that life got kicked off so
quickly and the fact that we emerged so
comparatively quickly might also suggest
that it's woven into the fabric of the
cosmos.
That this is a [inaudible].
If it was a really,
really,
really rare thing,
then you would have expected the earth
to be a dead gaseous bowl for billions
of years.
Many,
many more billions of years.
And it was.
So.
I'm not convinced by that.
And I think also you might be
underestimating just how mindbogglingly
huge the cosmos is and how little access
to it we have,
like the fact that we haven't found
anything yet doesn't mean anything.
I mean there are a hundred billion
stars,
Justin,
our galaxy.
So there are a hundred billion suns,
Justin,
our galaxy,
and there are billions of galaxies in
the universe.
Every single style that we see in the
night sky is inside our galaxy.
And of course that's only a tiny,
tiny,
tiny fraction of our little corner of
that galaxy.
And then beyond that galaxy,
there are innumerable other galaxies.
Like the idea that we are,
as Carl Sagan said,
you know,
the great scientists,
like if were the only intelligent life
in the cosmos,
that is an awfully large backdrop.
Like,
why bother?
Why is it all.
And no one's saying that we're not,
we're the only.
Well,
the,
uh,
there also is the theory that the
universe is so incredibly large that not
only is there an exact replica of earth
out there,
but infinity,
which is what the universe is supposed
to be.
Infinite is that not only is there an
exact version of earth out there,
there's everything that has happened on
this planet in the exact same order up
to me touching that microphone right
there has happened exactly down to the
Nanosecond,
an infinite number of times throughout
space,
like that's how big the universe is,
but it doesn't mean that someone's ahead
of us.
It doesn't mean that it doesn't mean
that,
but it does mean that intelligent is
very likely scattered throughout the
entire cosmos,
but it doesn't necessarily mean that
intelligent life has reached a place
past where we are right now.
It doesn't necessarily mean that,
but if but,
but I think that you would be well
advised to believe that it probably has
just because the median is usually a
better assumption then the extremes.
Right?
So I mean the,
the likelihood is that we're not at
either of the,
either of the very,
very extreme that we're not at the very
first nor the very last civilization.
Just statistically,
if you were just tossing a coin,
you would expect our civilization to
just happen to be clustered somewhere on
a bell curve in roughly the middle.
That's just a less anomalous statistical
thing to have happened.
Yeah,
most certainly.
I mean,
I'm definitely not decided on it.
I think it's just a possibility.
It's a possibility that this is it.
This is about a smart as anything has
ever gotten ever in the entire existence
of the universe.
That's depressing or not.
Or pretty fucking cool.
Like where the ballers or the universe,
yeah,
maybe this,
uh,
this system that they're going to put up
with this brush and billion is money.
Uh,
I was looking at the end exactly what
it's going to be able to do.
So astronomers,
they're going to be able to examine 1000
star systems for any sign of as being
used because apparently radar is a good
way of telling that someone is,
is there,
may have invented it,
and it's going to be able to detect a
laser with the output of an ordinary 100
watt light bulb from $23,000,
billion miles away.
That's the distance of the nearest
stars.
Twenty 3 trillion miles away,
there'll be able to spot a laser with
the wattage of an ordinary household
bulb.
What I was going to say about the other
possibility is the other possibility is
what I believe we're heading towards
right now is that we're heading towards
a virtual universe and that we're
creating something with the possibility
of artificial intelligence and the
possibility of living inside of some
artificial reality that they've created
that your brain interfaces with.
That there's going to be no need for
traveling anywhere or no need even for
the type of carbon based life
civilization that we currently enjoy and
it won't exist anymore,
and then we're going to create
artificial life and that the artificial
life is the next stage of evolution.
And then will we are is some sort of a
cosmic caterpillar that's going to
become a butterfly.
And that's one of the reasons why we're
so obsessed with shiny brand new laptops
and innovation and beautiful
materialistic items,
is that that has the mechanism and the
fuel behind creating those things.
Our obsession with these newer,
better,
greater things.
It's fueling the creation of these
newer,
better create greater things and they're
ultimately going to lead to artificial
intelligence.
Yup,
and that's what Elon Musk is.
That was just about to say,
look at what Elon Musk and Stephen
Hawking is saying about if,
and you know Sam Harris,
who I know is a friend of yours and I'm
a huge fan of Sam's and I've spoken to
him on huffpost live about this with the
idea that we are really not
understanding the potential of creating
artificial intelligence systems that
self improve in a way that they end up
getting sort of exponentially more self
aware until they're actually outsmarting
us and they have in every meaningful
sense a sense of their own existence in
the same way that we might.
In the same way that norm,
that biological intelligence does.
That is going to be a game changer.
The likes of which,
as you say,
I mean maybe biology just gets
extinguished or maybe we.
Maybe we end up,
I don't know.
It's like,
you know,
I don't,
I don't.
I'm kind of agnostic on the question of
whether or not we could ever upload our
consciousness into a silicon based form
for that.
I'm too dumb to make that.
Uh,
you know,
when,
when people start going to the
singularity thing,
I had a chance to talk to him for a
long,
did an interview with him for Saifai,
sat down for him with him,
just me and him chatting about this for
about an hour and a half.
The end of it.
I was fairly convinced that it's
inevitable,
fairly convinced that it's like if you
look at like the invention of the wheel
and then you look at the Cadillac that
we just showed today and,
or the mosque sake.
The Tesla is new insane Tesla that he
has.
It's all electric.
Goes zero to 60 in less than three
seconds.
Yes.
Fucking insane.
These things that we've created,
and these are just the beginning.
We're not going to stop there.
We're not going to go.
Yeah.
I think zero to 60 in three seconds.
That's good.
Let's stop right there.
We're not going to.
What?
I want to stop,
but isn't there a.
he's making a philosophical case as
well,
and,
and this is why I say I'm agnostic about
it because I did philosophy at
university and one of the big thorny
questions in philosophy of mind is
whether or not it's necessary to have
the biological substructure of a of a
brain in order to have a mind.
Could you disentangle those two things?
Could the experience of me feeling like
myself and feeling like I'm alive be
disentangled from the biological reality
of my physiology and the gray stuff in
between my ears.
Kurzweil's assumption,
which is basically just taking on faith
is yes,
you could disentangle that.
If you could replicate all of the data
that's whirring around in my head right
now as I'm saying these words as I'm
sitting here talking to you.
If you could take all of the things that
are going on,
all the electrical impulses,
all of those neurons,
all of those synapses,
and you could replicate that in a
computer.
Then that computer would be me and it
would not just seem like me.
It would feel like me,
like I would be.
I could actually be uploaded to a
computer and you could kill my body and
I would be existing in some really
meaningful sense.
I would be a model.
I think we're entirely too attached to
the idea of me or of us.
I think we're entirely.
You're too attached to the idea of this
even being a good structure.
I think we are so entangled with our
chimpanzee DNA.
We're so entangled with our our monkey
needs that we think that these have.
I would want to be downloaded into a
computer and that computer would be me
and I would share all my hopes and fears
and dreams.
Why the fuck would you want those?
And we're gonna have like youtube haters
that are in our artificial world that we
created and we're going to recreate them
in the exact same way.
God.
Imagine the trolls when you're actually
inside the computer,
inside the Matrix.
Well,
that's what I'm selling,
like haters and jealousy and anger and
misplaced fear and homophobia and the
the hatred of xenophobia,
all these different bizarre,
angry things that we have that make up a
human being.
All these nationalism,
all these different strange things that
we've sort of just become inexorably
attached to in our culture that we're
trying to eradicate,
but we never seem to quite do.
All of those things are a part of the
monkey body,
right?
But that monkey bodies,
what we're trying to save,
we're trying to save that and downloaded
into consciousness.
What if we can purify consciousness and
remove it from emotion removed from
biological need and even sex?
You know,
one of the things that freaks me out
about aliens,
not that I believe in aliens,
but the the iconic image of the alien is
always sexless.
They're smooth,
they have smooth genitals,
they have no muscle there,
totally undefined.
You can't tell what's a male or a female
and they have these enormous heads.
Is it possible that we have this iconic
image because we kind of know and
understand that ultimately the only way
we're going to transcend this monkey
body is to move past all the needs that
we've sort of automatically associated
with being alive.
Being alive means,
you know,
you have to kind of find food.
I've got to be a prepper.
I got to make sure that I have canned
foods and my band water.
What if it goes down?
I got to stay,
stay alive.
Stuff.
It's all live.
It's all about the monkey body and
that's why people want to be sexy.
I've got to get my lips done.
They're too skinny and one wants a fuck.
You know,
all that crazy shit that people have in
their brain is.
A lot of it is monkey body leftover
stuff.
Well,
I think that's an interesting theory
about why the alien,
why the model of the cliched alien is
like that.
Like a more,
in other words,
a less advanced conception of humans is
like Harrier.
Racism also plays into this,
right?
Darker skinned,
you know,
with features that are more kind of
monkey like or something.
Uh,
and then the more advanced conceptions
of civilization is white man with his
tools and everything.
If you extend that,
if you extrapolate from that,
then yeah.
More hairless,
I suppose,
less prone to sex,
less driven by animal desire.
It's also,
it's a huge factor in religion.
I think we're,
you know,
religions are so hung up about sex
because it's what links us,
it's what makes us animals and they
don't want to think of us as animals.
Then when I think of us as being
defined,
we are touched by the spark of God in a
way that no other animal lives according
to religion.
So you've got to quash six because the
and,
and gluttony,
because those are reminders that we're
just prime,
right?
But meanwhile,
the depictions of God,
he's ripped,
ripped and he's always wearing a robe
because he's modest.
He's reaching over and touching people.
His fingers go,
he's got giant traps and what's great,
it's true.
God looks at his son,
his son's looking great on the cross,
beaten to death,
and he's got abs and really watch for a
dice was for a guy,
was living in the Middle East 2000 years
ago,
but skin of bronze,
hair of wool,
bullshit.
The,
uh,
the other possibility of a black planet.
Chuck d was right.
There you go.
That.
Look at that.
Look at God.
Beautiful.
The dude on the left hind a little
robbed.
That's what I'm saying,
not even,
I mean why even draw it?
You might as well just make him an alien
with no genitals.
People back then just had little or
Dick's.
Is that possible?
It's possible,
but I've always just assumed that that
it's the modesty of the artist like it.
It kind of changed the frame of the
picture of God reaching down and
touching men.
If men had a massive schlong just
hanging down his leg.
Yeah,
it would be distracting if you're just
giant John Holmes Hog,
but look how big the muscles are in
these guys.
Like these guys have to be fucking
crossfitting all day as well as being
divine.
I mean that guy on the left is doing a
lot of fucking weightlifting.
That is not a regular body.
That's a body of someone who's picking
up heavy shit all day long,
but it's got a skinny neck.
I bet he's never been choked.
Maybe that's not a guy who knows how to
get out of a choke.
No Little Dick Skinny neck,
but giant fucking biceps,
forearms that does a lot of the.
There's a lot of weight lifting for
sure.
Michelangelo's ceiling of the Sistine
Chapel and look at the bizarre image of
God being supported by Cherubs.
So weird people are religion.
Can't see God's Dick Though.
Notice that.
Nope.
He's got a robot.
That other dummy was little tiny Dick.
God looks kind of.
I haven't really noticed this before,
but God on the ceiling of the Sistine
Chapel looks a bit like Meryl Streep.
Meryl Streep with a bad because I think
he's kind of got breasts and he's,
he's wearing like a nice white robe.
He looks like an old American actor and
I can't remember his fucking name
whether it's.
John has a little maybe,
maybe,
maybe.
Anyway,
anyway,
on the,
uh,
out of just getting better at one girl
though.
Hold on,
go back to that picture.
Look at the one that's in the crook of
his elbow.
She's fucking hater.
Hater.
She doesn't like that dude.
That dude's getting all the love.
She's like,
fuck that shit.
It was a little Dick.
Look at her face.
She's not filled with love.
She was like,
whatever,
uh,
on the,
on that question of the evolution of,
of humans creating like maybe,
maybe computers and artificial
intelligence of the next stage and maybe
that's maybe the universe is full of
like artificial intelligence that isn't
sending out the signals that we're
looking for when we're looking for
biological intelligence.
Right.
Maybe they don't need right as anymore.
They don't need to be losing laces
because they were all in,
in,
in computers.
The
other possibility which is similar to
that and which is very depressing and
which I don't particularly like,
is that once a species becomes capable
of destroying itself,
that they usually do,
like you can't get beyond like,
no,
you're not responsible enough to be able
to handle the kind of industrial scale
destruction,
destructive capacity that we now have
with nuclear weapons and with coal fired
power plants.
And with all of our ability.
We're so successful as a species that
were successful enough to destroy
ourselves,
but not yet wise enough not to do so.
And then maybe that's a trap that lots
of species fall into as they try to pass
through the crucible of going from being
ordinary animals to hyper-intelligent a
self self-aware animals,
but then on the way they invent tools
that they aren't yet mature enough to be
able to handle properly and they end up
wiping themselves out.
Well,
it's certainly possible.
And if we look at the universe as being
infinite,
the infinite possibilities exist as
well.
So probably all the pitfalls,
like all the things that we avoid it,
like the Cuban missile crisis,
maybe they didn't avoid and maybe they
were wiped out and maybe they did toxify
their atmosphere to the point where they
didn't recover for hundreds of thousands
of years and mutants and freaks barely
made it by,
you know,
running from hybrid wolves that have
fucking glowing red eyes.
Who knows what has been done.
Right?
So what kind of genetic engineering has
been done on these planets?
It's been run amok and fucked everybody
of the movie.
Uh,
we in what version of what we've done in
Australia with foxes and rabbits is out
of control nature experiments that have
really gone all fucked up wolves in
Idaho that are out of control,
how much of that has been done in these
other places as well as genetically
modifying things to the point where it
doesn't work anymore.
And that's,
that's also possible.
Absolutely.
And what's sort of staggering to me is
getting an insight into how recently we
have invented all of this stuff and
change the world like this.
Like I was,
I was in Athens during the great
financial crisis just in the week after
they had the big no vote was the week
when it really looked like grace was
going to crash out of the eurozone about
what,
four or five weeks ago.
And uh,
we went to the Acropolis,
the Parthenon because you know,
that's what you do.
And I was standing there in the museum,
like looking at all this stuff and I was
struck not so much by how incredibly
ancient it is.
Like this is the birthplace of
civilization,
right?
I mean,
this is where it all began.
This is the birthplace of Western
civilization basically,
but I was amazed at how actually
comparatively recent that is.
Like I was saying earlier that my
grandmother just died.
She was a hundred.
I can conceive of her lifetime.
Right.
I knew her like that's a long lifetime,
but it's not inconceivably long as a
period of time.
She was born before the roaring
twenties.
Think of that.
Yeah.
She was born in Nineteen 15.
She was born during the Gallipoli
campaign in the first world war,
but.
So anyway,
that's a span time that I can wrap my
head around.
You have 30 or 40 of those and you're
back at the Acropolis,
right on the banks of the birthplace of
Western civilization.
That is not a number.
That's like the hundred billion stars in
the galaxy that I can't wrap my head
even begin to wrap my head around.
It's not a number like the billions of
years that the earth is all that I can't
wrap my head around.
That's a very measurable,
understandable thing.
The birth of Western civilization is
just 30 or 40 of my grandmother's long
and then think about the fact that when
she was born there were no nuclear
weapons,
was no nuclear power.
We haven't discovered any of that stuff.
Right?
This is so recent.
We are.
We have the privilege of being the
generation,
the couple of generations that are
witnessing the,
the dawn of the beginning of something
extraordinarily new,
a,
the capacity to destroy ourselves using
nukes and environmental degradation and
be the rise of artificial intelligence
and in computing and mobilization.
You look at that,
the Acropolis,
the parthenon was crazy.
The Acropolis is the building,
right and the Parthenon is
built on the Acropolis is the whole
thing I think,
and I think the Parthenon is the
building.
Am I getting that back to front?
I'm not sure,
but the.
The bottom line is when you talk to
Greek scholars and they talk about the
construction of the building on top,
it was built on Samba,
something that was even more ancient and
they don't exactly know who built.
They don't exactly know who built the
platform that fucker was put on and then
you go back to crazy things like Baalbek
and Lebanon where they have these
enormous stone things that thousands and
thousands and thousands of tons and
they're like,
well,
what the fuck bill?
How'd they build these?
Would they do with these where these
things fucking come from?
And they really don't know.
And that brings up the possibility that
we haven't had a linear progression from
a man to this,
but we've had these ups and downs and
we've been at partially wiped out.
There is a,
there's a series of super volcanoes all
over the world and one big one being in
yellowstone that everyone's terrified
of,
but there's one of them,
I believe in Indonesia that there's a
certain theory that links to a massive
eruption of this supervolcano 70,000
years ago.
That is the reason why we all share
this.
Um,
so little genetic diversity.
And they believed that we might have
been down to a few thousand people
somewhere around 70,000
years ago.
We were down to,
I mean scientists,
evolutionary biologists can tell that we
were down to,
I don't know if it's as low as that,
but certainly,
I mean it was tens of thousands of
people and I know when that was,
but I remember you mentioned that
Supervolcano last time I was on this
show and then I went and googled it and
it was,
and it was like a probably didn't
happen.
Like most of the expert sites that I
went and looked at was like,
this is kind of one of those sort of
conspiracy theory things that we don't
actually think happened,
but whether or not it was that
particular Indonesian super volcano or
not,
we do know that there have been periods
where humankind has,
has almost gone extinct and we've just
gotten through that.
Well,
human beings have been in this form for
who knows how long,
you know,
like a million years,
whatever it's been there without a doubt
has been an eruption of yellowstone in
that time period.
So if there were human beings in North
America 600,000
years ago,
those fuckers were cooked and we're do.
We're done.
Every six to 800,000
years,
yellowstone blows and it is a continent
killer,
it will fuck up everything in the
continent and caused some sort of a
nuclear winter effect to a vast majority
of the world except maybe like
Australia,
Australian passport.
I was going to scrape back to the
Homeland New Zealand,
go and kill some foxes.
That might be the spot to spot because
there's a real but didn't have to deal
with what they're doing at [inaudible]
dot com.
That poor bastard Kim got.com.
You don't know what's going on with him
with that Mega upload site and just
trying to extradite him to a country
that he's not even from.
Show him that this was a super
volcanoes.
Valpo is an amazing.
I said what we're looking at here for
people who are listening to the podcast
is yellowstone and then turbo,
which looks like it's in Indonesia and
Tampa,
which is was a mega volcanoes,
so tell my uncle actually is a.
is like a melody.
I have maddy on my side.
Yeah.
Wow,
that's cool.
Again,
those crazy face tattoos.
I didn't have a tattoo on my back,
which is a symbol and to tempo is,
is an old extinct volcano when it blew,
they will.
There are writings of people in Italy
talking about how the sunset is,
how like the sky is red at sunset and
that's because of the ash from a volcano
on the opposite side of the world and is
currently a crater that is so big,
like it's a lake that you can reach a
huge,
like huge.
Like,
and that whole thing was just a stream
of lava just exploding.
Like it's you can you stand on the side
of the lake and you're like this.
I can't even imagine what kind of
Armageddon that must've been back when
it was active.
Well,
our stability,
the stability that we've enjoyed over
the past several thousand years that
people have written about,
I mean other than,
um,
what was the one that happened in Rome
or what was the,
what was it based on pay?
Yeah,
the Pompei one,
which was a fairly famous because we've
actually found people that were killed
and we could see their bodies and
there's,
there's an exhibit somewhere where they
have the bodies of the people from palm
pay,
the preserved ones on display somewhere.
What's supposed to be really freaky,
but that,
that was a major,
a minor one in comparison to
yellowstone.
They didn't even.
There it is.
Those are the people that were fucking
frozen in time and cooked and killed by
this.
It's just insane.
Those are actual real human beings.
I mean,
it looks like some claymation animated
thing.
That's incredible.
But the um,
what they believe is that,
well,
they didn't even know.
Here's another thing they didn't even
know about yellowstone until they
started looking at it from satellites.
They had no idea it was a Caldera
volcano.
They knew that there was some sort of
thermal activity because of old
faithful.
They knew there was some lava going on
under there,
but they didn't know how big the thing
was until they started looking at it
with satellite imagery and then they
realize what,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
This thing is like 600 kilometers wide
and what it is is a mountain that
explodes and leaves this crater and
that's what it called dairy is.
It reaches this explosion and the whole
mountain fly.
You got 300 mile wide mountain shoots,
lava up into the sky and just kills
everything.
Everything anywhere on the west coast.
All this is dead.
It's funny how we have a kind of.
There's a sort of cognitive dissonance.
It comes back to what we were talking
about,
about like the doors of perception and
how our brains are forced by evolution
and to keep us in a very narrow mindset
where we don't think about the reality
of what's going on around us and how
vast everything is and so on.
Because I think sometimes about like my
friends who live in San Francisco,
San Francisco is going to be devastated
by a massive earthquake.
It's just gonna happen when this to La.
San Francisco goes,
they look at you.
I'm Las Vegas.
San Francisco goes,
there's going to be awful,
but oh yeah,
but he's gonna go to La.
Is Ballet as being no las.
He's saying much San Francisco is a
innovation Langley to be to be more
devastated,
likable,
more likable,
more technical,
having wood's put in my mouth.
I'm a paranoid paranoid or you,
uh,
so anyhow,
at the store,
that is great.
That's what I felt like you were saying,
but you know,
we know this is going to happen and we
all go about our daily lives and we
don't pay any attention to it because we
couldn't because we would be paralyzed
if we kept thinking isn't going to be
today,
is it going to be tonight?
Then we'd just be.
I mean that's OCD,
right?
So we are forced to go through life not
wrecking will not actually reckoning
with the fact that that's going to
happen and yellowstone is going to
happen and all kinds of stuff's going to
go down and there's not a thing we can
do about it then.
Then there's asteroids,
asteroidal impacts of the big one,
the,
all the evidence that they're finding
now about all the different impact
craters that they have ignored or not,
not been aware of until recently.
The discovery of what they called,
I think it's called Triton nine,
it's nuclear glass,
that that exists on nuclear test sites
and also made meteor a meteor impacts
that they've founded all throughout Asia
and all throughout other parts of Europe
from 12,000
years ago and they think that that
coincided with the end of the ice age at
the end of the ice age or might have
been instigated by massive astro
asteroids and impacts all over the world
like 12,000
years ago.
That might have been why there is this
really old structures that are sort of
unexplained and this sort of resurgence
of civilization.
Somewhere around the 10,000
year mark that we have this big
downfall.
People start figuring things out again,
just like if you go back 2000 years from
now,
you know,
you're talking about Greece,
you're talking about ancient Rome,
and then 2000 years later you have New
York City,
right?
Well,
2000 years after this media,
real media in most terrible words.
I'm using girl.
I'm trying to.
I'm trying to say like a weather
reporter.
Jet Lags triploid along flat.
Yes.
Asteroidal and I'm drinking now.
You've had a half beer.
That's all I need.
New.
Was this fucking Nuevo New Mexican beer?
Yeah,
that's good.
Um,
but they think that it's very possible
that civilization has experienced many
of these.
Oh,
that's what Graham Hancock is based,
like a tremendous amount of his work on.
I don't know if you're aware of him,
but he's a good friend and he wrote a
book called fingerprints of the Gods.
It's based on exactly that.
All this evidence that shows that their
civilization has experienced these peaks
and valleys and that things have
happened,
that there have been some resets and it
hasn't been as simple as people figured
out fire.
Then they figured out they.
And here we are today in New York City.
I don't know if I mentioned it last time
I was on the podcast or not,
but there's an amazing kind of study and
there's an amazing article about this
sort of research which is if society
collapses and we still have nuclear
waste in the ground,
how do we mark our nuclear waste sites
such that a future civilization who has,
who's completely from us?
Doesn't speak our language,
has no more records of anything that
went on so that they don't go and hurt
themselves by digging it up,
and so there's the actual there a
semiotician and like all these people
who study the nature of symbols and of
and of conscious interpretation of the
ways that we communicate and everything
who have got these crazy ideas like
putting up these big kind of structures
that look like big scary angled polls
that get deeper and deeper and thicker
and thicker as you get towards the site
of where the nuclear waste is being
stored to try to indicate to future
intelligent civilizations.
Not to go in there,
but then the conclusion that they always
reach is they're just going to think
they're going to be interested in it.
They're going to want to explore it.
Right?
It's like if even if they understood
that,
we're saying that there is this
invisible radioactive stuff.
If they haven't yet,
like devise the concept of nuclear
power,
then they're just going to treat it the
way that we treat the warnings on the
pyramids saying,
don't go into the mummies because they
know you'll get a tech by spirits were
like,
oh,
that was a nice fun thing for you to say
you old fashioned people in ancient
civilizations,
but we're going to go in and open the
tomb anyway,
and so the conclusion was don't do
anything.
Just don't mock it at all.
Don't try to communicate it because
human curiosity is always going to be
more,
not even human curiosity.
Maybe like whatever this future species
is there,
curiosity is going to be more powerful
than any warning that we could possibly
give them because this stuff last for
tens sometimes hundreds of thousands of
years.
Yeah,
we really fucked up that whole nuclear
power thing.
I was trying to explain to someone who
is a.
he's a pretty staunch conservative and
he was saying how clean nuclear power is
relatively.
And I said,
do you understand that nuclear power has
only been around since the 19 forties
and we already in this brief moment of
time,
we already have three spots that we can
never go to.
They're done like,
Chernobyl is done,
fucked,
you know,
and the Fukushima is fucked.
That's fucked.
You know,
there was the other one,
the mile island,
three mile island,
wherever it,
it was really fucked.
Yeah.
But that's still three spots that they
fucked up already.
Never to,
not even to mention all the ones that
are based in the same technology that
Fukushima was.
When they can't really shut them down.
They,
they,
they have these archaic fucking nuclear
power plants they build when they didn't
really understand nuclear power plants.
Have you heard of pebble shell reactors
or something like that?
Um,
pebble.
Hang on,
let me see if I can find.
Because there is apparently a type of
reactor now where if anything goes
wrong,
it automatically shuts down.
Like it's a physiological thing.
Were they having a,
it's called a pebble bed reactors,
a graphite moderated gas cooled nuclear
reactor.
It's apparently,
I believe scientists when they say that
there are new types of reactors that are
basically meltdown proof.
My concern is I just think it's so
woefully irresponsible to do something
that,
you know,
producers waste,
fits incredibly deadly.
That's gonna last for thousands and
thousands of times longer than any of us
or any of our children or any of our
grandchildren or great grandchildren.
It could be around and just leave it up
to other people to deal with.
And I hear conservatives,
so a pro nuclear people say,
well,
we'll figure it out eventually.
Okay,
great.
Let's not use nuclear power until we
figure it out then because otherwise you
just,
you fucking with other people's lives.
People don't think like that though.
They think short term and they just try
to make as much money as possible.
That's true.
Noble today.
Um,
there's a great documentary that I
watched on the plane back from Brazil.
Merchants of doubt.
It was.
Have you seen it?
Yes.
Remind me what it is.
Because I think I interviewed the film
fucking fascinating.
It is about fake experts essentially get
hired by oil companies,
tobacco companies to poo poo the
concerns and debate them ferociously.
The concerns about global warming
concerns.
They used to do the concerns about
tobacco being or nicotine being
addictive and causing cancer and this
guy shows that that when when there's
money involved,
they.
What they do is they hire all these
people to fuck with the argument and
they write op Ed columns and all these
different newspapers all throughout the
country and they constantly hammer so
that your grandfather reads and he goes,
I've read a thing today is at 31,000.
Scientists have said that global
warming's not real.
We know who is amongst those 31,000
scientists,
Michael J Fox.
That was one of it.
One of the names,
they're fake.
It's fake names and they have Michael
Shermer on.
It's kind of explaining that he's great.
At one point in time he thought that
there was,
that it was nonsense that global warming
is nonsense.
And then he started delving into the,
the actual data,
the actual scientific papers,
and then he realized,
well,
there's not only is there a consensus
that man made global warming is a real
thing,
but there are no peer reviewed studies,
no scientific papers that indicate the
opposite.
None,
zero,
Zilch.
I interviewed the director of that movie
on,
on huffpost live.
So I did see the movie on a screen up
beforehand.
And um,
it,
the amazing thing to me was that it's
not just the same tactics that are being
used in sowing doubt about climate
change as well.
Used in sowing doubt about all kinds of
other different things,
you know,
starting bestest,
bestest,
all this sort of stuff.
It's the same human beings.
Yes,
yes.
These are professional.
That's why it's called merchants of
doubt.
These are the same human beings who went
in and fought for the tobacco lobby who
then went and fought for the asbestos
industry who are now fighting for the
fossil fuel companies.
Exactly the same human beings using
exactly the same playbook,
using exactly the same.
And those,
those Goddamn television shows where
they have the split screen where they
have the host and then they have the two
experts debate it out,
and then have one person who's like Bill
Nye,
who's sort of a reasonable scientist is
saying things that people can't totally
understand because they're a little bit
too tactical and then you have this
shouting guy who like fact 23,000
scientists from 40 countries have said
global warming's not real fact.
The United States and went along and the
they,
they have this playbook that they use.
They have this style of communicating in
these short bursts because those shows
only last.
You have seven minutes,
you have seven minutes.
There's three people there were all
talking.
It's so hard to get a point across and
it.
It's one of the reasons why I think it's
one of the shittiest ways to discuss a
subject.
Totally.
This is one of the things that I really
spend a lot of time trying to do in my
job,
which is overturn this phony sense of
balance that is required.
It's so every journalist in every media
person tries to be anyone who's good has
instilled in them a sense that they're
supposed to be fair,
right,
but that often gets misallocated,
especially at places like CNN,
for example,
where they're trying to be genuinely
even handed,
but what they think that means is giving
a microphone to the two people at either
side of any particular debate.
Now there are some debates where one
side is right and one side is wrong,
right?
Or there's a 98 percent chance that one
side is right and a two percent chance
that the other side is right.
When you try to be balanced by just
sitting in the middle and trying to
moderate a debate between those two
people,
you're actually not being unbiased at
all.
You're being biased towards false hood
instead of towards truth.
So whenever I have have a weekly segment
about science news called the nerds
forum on Huff Post live,
and I always try to try to explain to
people and express,
look,
this is the likelihood that this thing
is actually true.
So let's talk about the science and
let's not get caught up in this trap of
false equivalencies.
It's like,
where did you say a call?
Bam.
Did a bit about.
No,
it wasn't cold.
Barrows.
John Oliver did a bit.
And the same guy.
Same Guy.
John Oliver is a different guy.
Does he have an English accent?
He has an English accent,
new character.
The Colbert.
Stephen Colbert is a human being.
So John,
although he's not anymore,
he's the host of the late show.
Oh right.
Kobe is no more carry on.
So John Oliver did this bit where he was
like a.
instead of having a pro climate change
person and an anti climate change
person,
uh,
we think that we should actually reflect
the proportions accurately since 99
percent of climate scientists believe in
it.
They have one.
So he brings out nine.
Nine people come on sand and they're all
just shouting,
oh,
actually pro the pro climate change
position.
And there's this one other guy who's
chatting the etsy climate change
position.
And he's like,
this is what it actually is like.
It's not one for one,
it's $99 for one,
and that's how the media should portray.
That's hilarious.
That's a great idea.
By the way,
there really is a great idea.
Idea.
Yeah.
I think that those shows are horrible
because they're.
This is how a lot of people get their
information and they say they call it
the news in quotes,
but it's not really the news.
It's an entertainment show and it's an
entertainment show that relies on
commercials,
so you this balanced nuanced
perspectives and arguments that are
extremely complex like we like we spent
all this time talking about the
conservation for hunting argument and
all the artificial intelligence
argument,
the argument,
the argument about pursuing it.
All these things are real complex,
nuanced issues that require long sort of
detailed examinations of all the
possibilities and not from a biased
perspective but from as objective as is
humanly possible,
especially when there's real
ramifications.
Things like global warming or nuclear
energy or things that really are gonna
fuck up our generation and generations
to come like the hundreds of thousands
of years from now.
Those don't get addressed when you have
seven minutes and you have a guy who's
being paid by these think tanks and
that's what's crazy about this merchants
of doubt,
a documentary is it shows that there's
these people that are paid by think
tanks and these think tanks.
What they really are is they're these
fake organizations that are propped up
by companies that are selling whatever
the fuck they would benefit from this
being passed or this being the.
The concerns being alleviated.
One of them being like this doctor who
was a paid by this think tank to go and
preach about these flame retardant
fabrics and materials using to make
furniture and that he would say this
story about a woman who left a candle in
the babies was a cigarette,
wasn't a candle.
She said a candle.
She left it.
There was a cigarette story too,
but there's a woman left a candle in her
baby's crib and that the baby,
because the pillow was flame retardant
leaves a candle in a baby's crib
annually.
Exactly.
It wasn't a real story.
It was a lie and this guy had told not
that story,
not just once,
but several times over a long period of
time,
over many years,
and these people started investigating
the merchants of doubt.
Go Watch the documentary.
It's amazing.
Amazing.
And they started investigating this
doctor and what did they call them up?
Did you actually treat these people?
They looked into his past.
His background is passed.
They did a computer database on all the
infants that died from burns in this
guy's a area and they found that it was
a lie and so they called him and he
said,
well,
this is an anecdotal thing and I would
trust it wasn't real.
I was just trying to paint a story of
what's possible.
No you fucking,
but he,
because he wasn't under oath because he
wasn't under oath when he was
testifying.
He was allowed to lie about this stuff.
When they asked him,
yeah,
I was paid for citizens for fire safety
or whatever the fuck that's the think
tank was.
And then when a think tank has less than
x amount of members,
you have to sort of disclose where the
funding comes from and the funding all
came from the manufacturers of this
flame retardants shit that is causing
all sorts of problems with children,
especially babies like babies around
this flame retardants stuff that dust
from that stuff gets in their lungs that
gets in their system and they showed
like the difference between the amount
of this shit,
it's an American babies versus the
amount of the shit that's in babies and
other countries where they don't have
these people lobbying to have the shit
be put in there.
Their furniture.
It's fucking terrifying.
I often wonder living in America why
cancer rights here are increasing at
the,
at the right that they are.
And you know why Fox News,
because you can answer this Washington.
I mean not those hot chicks or something
is going on right up.
That is not happening in Japan and it is
not happening in,
in other countries.
And I wonder whether it is stuffed like
industry's lobbying for fire safety.
Things that are.
So every time you sit down on your
couch,
you just a little bit,
you're just absorbing like the tiniest,
tiniest,
tiniest little bit of some shitty
chemical,
you know,
I don't want to get too hippy dippy
about it,
but like all the stuff that's in our
soaps and the teenager just the,
um,
the number,
you look at the ingredients on things
and they were just,
it's just a litany of chemicals.
It makes me,
it makes me want to move to New Zealand
and ate my,
My,
my grandmother's beautiful eggs from a
natural chicken and just use eucalyptus
oil to bathe myself in and sit on a
wooden chair.
Well,
I think you're right.
And I think though the argument is
pretty clear when you see things like
this merchants of doubt and you find out
how lobbyists work and you find out how
think tanks work and you find out how
these people are actively trying to get
these things,
get the concerns about these things that
alleviated.
And they're it strictly for financial
reasons.
That's it.
They're not doing it because they have a
real concern.
And it takes us a while before we figure
it out,
like thalidomide,
like thumb,
a little bit of my babies.
And that has to happen as best as people
have to get cancer,
they get rid of.
Especially now they're getting rid of
trans fats.
Trans fats are now illegal.
Well,
how many fucking people had to get sick?
I mean,
how long have trans fats and margarine?
I can't believe it's not butter.
How long has that shift been around?
It's been around forever and people have
lobbied in,
lied and promoted these things for their
own personal gain and profits.
And it's,
it's crazy.
But it's a real part of our culture.
It's a real part of our legal system.
It's a real part of how we,
we,
you know,
we create laws.
It's,
it's kind of scary.
It's kind of scary when you think about
how sociopathic it really is.
That's right.
And I do think that the,
again,
coming back to the media,
I think we have a big responsibility
because we own the media.
You will realize I wasn't,
I didn't mean to include you in the way
I was including nervous was including
me.
I mean you are.
You're part of the good part of the
media in so far as what the Internet is
now doing is allowing conversations like
this.
Like you say,
well,
how can you get to impart these ideas in
seven minutes?
I mean,
you're lucky if you get seven minutes on
exhibit TV,
you usually get three minutes.
If you're on the today show,
you get three minutes or something,
but how many people have time to listen
to a three hour podcast at one point 6
million twitter followers?
Yeah,
there's a lot now.
It's getting more now,
but it's also ridiculous that a former
fear factor host meatheads cage fighting
commentators smokes pot all the time,
is the guy that you come into for
information.
It seems like there should be someone
more qualified.
Well,
that's right.
That's right.
But I mean when there are like Sam
Harris and there's a lot more people out
there that are doing this as well,
but this medium,
I agree with you that this medium
absolutely genius of it,
and the problem is that people,
journalists,
and not don't tend to be scientifically
literate.
So when something comes out saying that
butter is a deadly killer and monitoring
is the answer,
then someone puts out a press release,
a PR company,
then some money from it,
from the modern industry,
and then the producer at the radio
station or television station who
receives that knows that that's a juicy
tidbit.
So they write it up and they do a story
on it and that's that all of a sudden
the viewer is under the impression that
this is a settled fact.
It's not a settled fact.
It's what was one study and in three
years' time module is going to be a
deadly killer and bought is going to be
good again.
But also in the
defense of the people that were
distributing that information,
there was very little known about
cholesterol back then.
LDL,
cholesterol,
hdl,
cholesterol.
What is the difference?
What was needed?
Scientific work has still been needed to
be done on a lot of different dietary
supplements and things that the data
wasn't in yet.
Right,
but Joe,
scientists will always speak with more
caveats than the media does.
Huge bug and scientists back then,
even if they hadn't known about ldl
cholesterol,
they would've said,
look on the basis of what we currently
understand about module and bought a and
human physiology,
blahdy,
blah.
That's not the way that it ends up
getting impounded because nobody wants
to watch a television show that
equivocates like that or a news
broadcast that equivocates like,
no,
I think
you're definitely right about that and I
also think that we're in a weird time
now where,
because of the Internet and because like
you could do huffpost live,
I don't know what kind of editorial
control they have over what you do.
Like when you finish.
I really enjoy your show,
by the way,
if anybody hasn't seen it,
the reason why I wanted to get you on
the show in the first place,
I've watched many episodes your show and
it's very balanced and until I like this
conversation,
it's a,
it's a cool show and it's,
and it's very unlike something that you
would see in normal NBC 8:00
PM or whatever the fuck it would be on
broadcast television.
It's just very different.
I think that that kind of stuff and that
the Internet and what the Internet,
the freedom that it provides and also
the freedom of Info,
the amount of information,
the access to it is kind of changing
the,
the ability of these people to do things
like that.
Yeah,
I agree.
Um,
did you say,
by the way,
this also just popped into my head while
we were talking.
Um,
Richard Dawkins tweet about feminism in
Islam.
Nobody saw him.
He said,
uh,
Islam needs a feminist revolution.
It will be hard.
What can we do to help and which seems
reasonable to me.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
the Internet just exploded.
I had I store,
it feels like they got mad at him.
Oh,
totally misogynistic.
How dare he has a white male.
Look,
I have these.
I still have these tabs up on my
computer because we were looking at it
as a white male.
Women who are forced to wear these crazy
outfits.
They cover their body.
They can't go to school.
They can't drive.
So look at the candidate vote ugliest
headlines.
Richard Dawkins,
mansplained feminism to Muslim women.
Atheist Richard Dawkins,
tweet file.
Richard Dawkins fail spectacularly on
feminism and Islam.
Who wrote these,
by the way,
they're all over the place.
Uh,
one of them's Napoleon pace in the huff
post.
One of them said,
yeah,
we made a blog.
What is the opinion blog?
What does it say?
That is the.
Hang on,
let me see if I was told that.
I think I,
I just saved the titles here.
Say so I don't have the uh,
there are so many people looking to call
bullshit on men that somehow or another
try to say anything about what women do
or need to do.
Like here's one twitter user says,
Richard Dawkins needs to abandon his
patronizing white savior,
paternalist,
Islamophobia like how many buzzwords can
you fit in a tweet?
How many politically correct buzzwords
can you fit?
That person's not real.
That's a Stephen Colbert,
Huffington post.
They're pretending to be a fucking
liberal conservative,
and then,
and then it was an article saying that
he's no better than early 20th century
European colonists,
Muslim women,
that they needed help from European men
even says,
what can we do to help?
It says,
Islam needs a feminist revolution.
It will be hard.
What can we do to help?
That's a beautiful tweet and it's
correct when look,
if you just look at it as human,
forget about Islam.
Forget about sex is.
Forget about all that gender's shit.
If you just looked at it,
there's a human being that's looking at
other human beings that are forced to
behave in a way that they might not want
to picture.
It has nothing to do with this.
Let's say it's a new group that starts
up tomorrow and they call themselves the
fucking monkey faces.
Joe,
you're ignoring the deep complexity of
so many different strains of Islam
around the world.
You're disempowering women of color,
western world.
What about white chicks that are Muslim?
You're,
you're a racist.
I just called you out and you don't call
out fucking racist.
There's a lot of white Muslim.
Of course.
I'm just so frustrating with.
Was sarcastic too.
I know.
What can you do?
How can we do it?
Here are people that are trying to call
bullshit on people when the bullshit
doesn't exist because they want a score
just like we were talking about earlier,
that cops want to arrest people because
it's a fucking game and they want to
win.
I think there's people that want to win
on twitter.
There's people that want to win on huff
post is people that are looking to write
blogs about a guy like Richard Dawkins
who has said some kind of weird,
questionable shit in the past.
Like especially the shit that he said
about child molesting that he was,
uh,
he experienced some mild molestation
when he was young.
No big deal.
Got over it.
You know,
like,
Whoa,
whoa.
What the fuck,
man,
if you listen to what he was actually
saying,
I think what he was,
I think what he was saying is get over
that we get,
we get,
we have certain paradigms of about which
we get very,
very upset and because abusing and
violently raping children is pretty much
the worst thing that you can possibly
do.
We have made it mandatory to regard all
child abuse as being the worst thing
that can possibly happen.
I think his point was like I was
funneled by by a stupid crazy priest
when I was 12 years old or something and
I pretty quickly got over it.
So that's not to say that other people
who didn't get over it and going through
didn't go through horrible things,
but do we have to regard every single
instance of every single type of crime
as equally bad?
Can we be a bit more nuance?
Like maybe they're a very,
very bad forms of child abuse and maybe
there are less bad forms of child abuse,
but the moment you say that,
everyone says he's saying a child abuse
is good.
Right?
Well,
and also this is a horrible thing to
say,
but I'll preface it by saying,
this is my own personal experience.
I was bullied when I was a kid,
but it was mild bullying,
like nobody did anything horrible to me.
I was never beaten half to death or I
was never.
Nobody ever threatened me with weapons.
I just kind of picked on and fucked
with,
but it got me into martial arts and it
changed my life.
Like these are the Yin and the Yang to
things and I think that sometimes take a
little bit of resistance is good because
the reaction to that resistance is you
decide like,
this is never going to happen to me
anymore.
I'm going to fire up and I'm going to
figure out a way to empower myself.
So this is no longer a fear of mine and
I think that a little bit of someone
being an asshole to you makes you
appreciate kind people.
I think the,
the evil people in the world.
And here's another one.
Shitty relationships.
I think most of us have had some bad
relationships,
bad relationships make you appreciate
good relationships.
You know,
like I,
I really appreciate one of the things I
really love about my wife,
she doesn't like to argue about shit.
She's like a really kind person.
She's friendly and sweet and warm and
she's not like a person like picks on
people and she like picks on you or
starts arguing or brings up shit that
happened like a month ago or a year ago.
I have a buddy that has a wife that
argues with them like that.
Well,
yeah.
Well you know,
when we were first dating you,
he's like,
that was fucking police fucking selling.
My body is different from the cells that
were in my body seven years ago.
I'm not responsible for that guy who
came home drunk and fucking shit already
apologized.
Exactly.
But it's not.
If anything comes up,
like if she does something wrong,
like if she doesn't pay a bill.
So was put the fuck the cables off.
Well you remember when we first started
dating and fucking yes,
I do remember that.
And it also has nothing whatsoever to do
with the conversation that we're having
right now.
Well,
you,
when you experienced that,
he fucked up and married this crazy
broad.
Sorry,
I said broad.
I'm an asshole.
Let me try to explain things.
It was white male privilege or ripping
into the microphone.
I split.
I spray that shit like come.
That's what I do with my white male
privilege.
I don't allow it to just ooze out like
maple syrup.
Um,
I think that when we see these terrible
things like when I go to,
I love Brazil.
Brazil is a wonderful country.
It's a,
the people are friendly,
they're free,
they're happy,
but it's also like kind of crazy
unorganized.
Like when you go to the airport,
like one of the things when we were
getting on a plane from Sao Paulo to
Brazil or Sao Paulo to Rio rather,
um,
the,
we couldn't find out what fucking gate
it was because they said 17.
See?
So we'd go to 17 c and the lady,
uh,
you know,
she speaks Portuguese.
So she's like,
no,
day 24,
20 5:00
AM I,
but it doesn't say 24 slash slash eight.
So we go to 24 and 24 says floor
Annapolis and it says another one next
to it,
like what the fuck?
But they were saying it over the
loudspeaker.
So all the people that are listening
that spoke Portuguese knew that it was,
but there was no signs because there
are.
It's a different world.
They have a different.
So it made me appreciate when you come
back to America,
you look up at the fucking departures.
Oh there's the gate.
Here we go.
You know what,
if you only spoke mandarin,
the true,
it'd be fucked.
You'd be fucked.
We fucking just a bad hit.
Even worse because if I spoke mandarin
and I was in Brazil,
I'd be double.
Fuck you.
You didn't even read what the fuck
they're writing and they couldn't know
what the hell you know,
you would go to your app on your phone
and try to decipher it.
But point being like when when you see
something like if you like,
if you go to like my buddy who went to
Africa and experienced like all the
chaos of Africa said God mean people
complain about America like you to go,
yes,
of course
it's not perfect.
There is no utopia on this planet who is
Denmark Utopia.
I mean it's just like,
I think there were degrees,
right?
Like obviously Africa and many South
American countries are going to be more
screwed up then rich countries like
America.
Right?
But then within the club of rich
countries,
there are also countries where shit just
works.
It just easy stuff is easy.
I lived in Copenhagen for a semester and
went to university there in my early
twenties and like,
you know,
there's no lines at the post office.
There's no,
I mean granted there's no people who
live there.
There's like 14 people in the whole
country.
But like it's still scalable.
You could actually have.
They still got a tax,
the same tax base per capita,
you know,
as America could have if it wanted to
have higher taxes and you could actually
have a dmv that that works and you could
have a post office that functions.
We don't have to wait around all the
time.
It's just A.
There's certainly societies that,
you know,
Thomas Friedman says that flying from
Schiphol airport in Amsterdam into JFK
is like flying from the,
from the jetsons to the Flintstones,
like laguardia is a shit hole.
Then that's just the way it is.
You know,
there are countries whose airports are
nice and who's trains of fast and these
healthcare systems work more cheaply.
The worst though,
the way the people treat you at
Laguardia,
there is so fucking over it and
aggressively over it,
like Shitty to you.
Oh,
New York Tsa workers are my least
favorite of all the TSA workers.
That's pretty bad.
So he asked them a question,
now that I've,
now that I've got,
I've got to tell you,
you're lucky that you have global entry.
Need to get it.
You gotta get it.
I'm a fucking idiot.
I mean,
[inaudible] damn it,
I just got my green card,
this,
I got my green card earlier this year
and done to our country.
So thank you very much.
I hope you enjoy it.
I appreciate it.
I've been in 10 years,
but uh,
you know,
just on temporary visas and uh,
now that I was able to get global entry,
just not having to deal with the customs
officials coming in,
especially in the foreign as lane.
I mean I imagine it may be better in the
city and the citizens lane,
but coming in and the foreign is lane
where you're in front of like they've
just had to deal with 478.
Like people who don't speak English who
are probably coming in with with some
lousy shit from abroad or chicken in
their back.
Yeah,
that's right.
Exactly.
In the backpack there no speak.
Oh,
how racist.
Josh zaps racist evolution.
It did not.
So he start tweeting.
Can we do to help asshole?
I can't believe what he just did a.
and so by the time I get,
I get up to the,
to the customs guy,
that pissed,
they're over it,
they're over me wherever,
everything.
So just being able to go to the kiosk
and swept the global entry and then just
walk straight through.
It's one of the greatest things.
All the guys I work with the UFC habit.
I'm the only one who doesn't.
I'm fucking moron.
It's not hard.
Just busy,
bro.
I'm doing a lot of podcasts and shit.
You are not a hard.
You make an appointment.
I go to cryotherapy five times a week.
I can't go to global entry apartment.
I'm.
Yeah.
You should not do it.
Should I agree with you?
I'm disappointed in myself as well.
He should be.
Yeah.
Is I wonder whether or not just on why
people are angry at Richard Dawkins for
saying something that obviously makes
sense.
I think they're not really angry.
I don't believe they are angry.
I don't.
You feel like
some people see the world in groups and
identities and for them identity
politics is the most important way of
contextualizing and conceiving of the
things that are happening around them in
culture.
So the moment a person who's a white
male starts saying anything,
they're like,
okay,
this is in the category of patronizing
white male authority.
Looking down on this other category of
person who is oppressed like religious
minority.
So let's not actually listen to what's
being said and let's not give anyone the
benefit of the doubt.
Let's just super impose that into the
jigsaw puzzle in my brain,
which is like culture.
And when you say it also in,
in all of the,
all of the racial problems that have
been happening in the past year in the
United States.
And I'm totally on the side of the black
lives matter movement here.
And I have a huge problem with,
uh,
with the brutality that police show
towards towards minority communities.
But you got to make sure that you're
actually talking on the same page about
the ideas and the practices that you're
not just caricaturing people into
stereotypes of one another.
Right.
And I think maybe that's what's
happening here.
I agree.
It might be.
I think that what's going on is like a
game of hungry,
hungry hippo and there's a little marble
and they see that you can snatch that
marble and they go for it.
I think it's an opening and I don't
think it's logical and you know what I
love,
I love when people who have these knee
jerk reactions to these things,
like they see these openings and they'd
go for it because they feel like there's
an opening to attack also get attacked.
Like there's a woman who wrote a piece,
she's a feminist and she wrote a piece
about my friend Amy Schumer who is
hilarious and wild and just fucking
awesome.
And she's kicking ass right now and
she's in the cover of a magazine sucking
on [inaudible] finger.
And there were saying why this magazine
is so awful about,
you know,
against feminism.
And I was like,
shit,
what the fuck are you like,
this is an antifeminist thing.
And she shouldn't be sucking fingers.
Like,
as if like you're a woman,
you can't be sexual,
you know,
like isn't it like part of being a
person who owns themselves owning all
the things you enjoy?
Maybe she likes sucking fingers,
you know,
like she's a fucking picture of it.
That's fun.
Bad ass bitch.
Look at her.
She's so good.
I love her.
She's gangster as fuck.
But here's the thing.
This same woman wrote a bit of,
she wrote another piece because I like
to follow knuckleheads showed another
piece about how she's getting older and
it's really kind of.
She's torn because she doesn't get cat
called much anymore.
She's actually getting.
She's actually as conflicting opinions
about this.
And so here's the tweet that drove me
crazy.
It made me laugh.
I howled at my own computer.
Someone tweeted her saying that this
article about being conflicted about not
being catcalled anymore.
I felt like that was a very white cis
piece.
White,
cisgender,
meaning that people of Color and trans
people have to worry about being
catcalled because trans people,
if their cat called and then someone
finds out that the trans,
they can get beaten to death and you
should be more aware that when you write
these pieces,
you're insensitive and true.
She could.
She had a.
She had to acquiesce.
She had to like give into it because
she's a part of that fucking retarded
culture.
Right.
So she got stuck in our own bullshit
ideology is the caveat.
Trans Women in particular,
but trans people in general are the
victims of violence that way.
Higher rates than everybody else.
So let's just put that aside and say
that that's a terrible thing and that we
should still be supportive of the Trans
community,
but I mean,
did you,
you heard about it was a college that
canceled the vagina monologues because
they were doing a production of the
vagina monologues,
this popular feminist play.
Yes.
The trend and the and the on campus
trends community,
not even the on campus trans community.
There wasn't an on campus trans
community.
The the on campus like liberal fucking
knee jerk douchebag decided it was
insensitive to trans to trans people
because not all women have vaginas.
Someone when that Dick's.
Yeah,
and not all people are people.
My dog has a person.
My dog identifies as a person.
I don't know if you know that.
I didn't know that.
Well,
you be.
Be more respectful and sensitive because
not all.
Not all dogs are actually.
Human beings are.
Not all people are human beings,
but I didn't.
I didn't follow that big live in fucking
fairy tale land.
That's what we are.
It's too easy to get food.
That's what's going on,
so people make up shit to get upset
about it.
That's my feeling.
It's too easy to just go to the
supermarket and pick up fucking cereal.
It's just too easy.
Here's the thing,
how you actually supposed to help
people.
How are we supposed to be kind and
considerate and generous.
Every time we try to we get shut down
because we put our foot in it.
Like Dawkins.
Dawkins in that tweet about Islam is
trying to support women.
Yes.
Like what could be wrong with that?
He tries to do that and then feminist
jumped down his throat for being
condescending towards women because
Muslim women should be the ones who were
sticking up for Muslim women.
They don't need your white,
patriarchal,
Islamaphobic male,
a activity to in order to do so because
they are proud and bold Muslim women.
Well,
not all of them are.
Some of them are in stuck in beekeepers
outfits in Saudi Arabia.
So how do we help them if every time we
try to help,
we get jumped.
We jumped on.
Well,
I think we have to negate the opinions
of those people that write these posts
for like the huff post,
write these articles.
We have to negate them by mocking them
because I think it is hilariously
stupid.
I think that that opinion is a fucking
hilariously
stupid that he doesn't have the right to
say that he has concern for people that
are a different gender than him that
have a different ideology than him.
They'd live in a different part of the
world and him that have more melanin in
their skin.
That's ridiculous.
And I think what we're doing here by
mocking that is really what the correct
response is.
The only correct response.
You're not going to get that response
from the news.
You're not going to get that from the
president,
but didn't you get that from people that
don't have a vested interest in
supporting one particular tribe.
And I think that's one of the things
that they talked about in this merchants
of doubt documentary that I have really
resonated with me,
is that a lot of times when people talk
about global warming or they talk about
fucking chem trails or any of these
things,
there is a tribe of people that have
subscribed to that ideology and it's
very important that you support that
tribe.
And it might.
It can it.
It manifests itself as in ridiculous
places like the tribe of people that are
like android phones.
They love android phones and they hate
iphones.
I have a friend who fucking hate.
She's.
She's brilliant.
She's a brilliant director.
She writes movies.
She's fucking great.
She hates Mac.
I hate Mac.
Everybody uses Mac.
I won't fucking use apple.
I use windows.
I'm like,
what are you talking about,
Patty Gimme a hug.
It's Goddamn computer.
Don't get viruses.
The other ones do.
You're such a powerful individual for
not being a Mac person.
Right.
It's like taking your.
Yeah,
your rebelliousness by going with the
world's largest computer company.
She knows.
It's ridiculous.
She laughs when I make fun of it,
but she just fucking sticks to her guns.
She fucking digs their heels in the
ground.
What about going?
Wraps are risks around a cord.
I'm not going anywhere.
Madness.
Those people who when a new product
comes out and it's usually an apple
product,
they'll go out and they'll camp for four
or five days in order to be the first
person who gets the light.
I do not under.
It reminded me a little bit of when you
were talking about your buddy who did
the massive mess of marathon,
but then came in fourth.
I always like I was watching,
I was watching the today show or
something where they were interviewing
the people who were standing in line and
they'd been there.
You know,
they've all got.
They've got tents and they got sleeping
bags like they were on fifth avenue,
like near Central Park and they're
sleeping on the sleeping,
camping for 72 hours and they were and
the correspondent was talking to someone
who was like the seventh in line or
something and I was like,
yeah,
I can understand spending a week outside
in to get the new iphone if you're
number one thing,
number seven,
even better than being like number 342.
What differences.
Oh,
I got the seventh iphone.
He's in the middle.
Like.
Do you think that that's what what,
what is,
what is it about people that are going
to get something that doesn't even do
anything different?
Yeah,
like the smartest person I know is this
woman,
Dr Rhonda Patrick.
She does my podcast,
all podcasts all the time.
She's absolutely brilliant.
She has an iphone four.
Right?
It's an old piece of shit.
It's the size of my thumbnail.
It doesn't even like run,
run,
run.
And I like.
There's so many apps,
like even now until I recently didn't
have any space on
my phone to five,
she's smarter than me.
I got a big fucking stupid six.
There you go.
That's the new thing is the new thing
one,
one generation back.
You know,
I didn't even realize there was a six.
Wow,
you're amazing.
I'm like that.
That's how cool I am.
The type of individual I am Joe.
I'm like,
I'm so like totes out of like the whole
like keep up with the Jones'
Gizmodo.com.
Live in Brooklyn and eat Kale.
Kale is even better because they don't
grow Kale in Brooklyn.
We have it flown in from Brazil.
So this,
I didn't have any room on my phone to
upgrade to the latest software.
So for ages I was still running the on
the older software and gradually your
apps just stop working.
Like stuff just doesn't even work.
Like you open up the American Airlines
APP and it's like this is no longer
supported by this software.
So they keep you up,
they keep you on your toes.
I still have an older software to have
the newest software because I don't have
a new software on my computer either.
I heard fucking crashes.
Um,
I wait a long time.
Man may take some time.
There's A.
I was to be in a plastic surgeon in
Australia about penile enlargement
surgery.
Done.
Ask.
Is it work?
Is that done at the end?
I have,
but um,
yeah,
but they're a bit.
It has some side effects.
What's the side effects?
Your Dick flips around in weird ways
when it.
That's when they cut the tendon.
Yeah.
That's not so it doesn't religion.
If you have a micro Dick,
what?
You're going to get an extra inch.
Woah.
Congratulations.
Now you have two inches.
It's mostly just for vain people.
It's not for micro Dick People,
but then also they can take fat out of,
out of other parts of your body and then
they'll put fat in around the edges,
but thins fat and smushy.
No one wants that.
Anyway,
my point is simply this,
I wasn't intending to talk about do a
little Dick.
Dude's getting getting bigger dicks
asteroids.
He said that there's a maximum in in
medicine that you should never be either
the first nor the last to adopt a new
procedure.
Hmm.
That's a good smart.
That's my way towards on phones.
I have my philosophy on technology on
the basis of penile enlargement surgery.
Well,
I wait a little while,
but I'm not the last person to adopt,
but I'm probably like third.
I'm like in the third wave.
I'm not enough.
I'm not waiting in line for shit.
I'll tell you that right now.
I'm not waiting in line for a fucking
phone.
It's never ran out the kinks anyway.
Unless the phone does like holograms.
Once you put the phone down,
help me Obi wan.
You're my only hope like Amy Schumer
pops up and fucking dances for you.
Then then I'll take it.
When that happens,
you're going to then realized that there
you go.
You'll be one of the first adopters and
then they'll realize it gives you.
It's radioactive and it gives you cancer
and you'll die.
God Damn it.
Turn your smartphone into a three d
hologram.
Is this real?
Oh my God.
So piece of glass.
You stick on your on top of your thigh.
Just tell us here.
That just popped in my head.
Why it makes a little hologram on your
smart phone.
Seriously,
using glass.
Well,
we're really close to these new goggles
that they're creating where even right
now
they look like ski goggles,
but eventually they're going to be like,
like sunglasses that are the new
desktop.
That is incredible.
Look at that.
That's amazing.
That's cool.
What does that magic leap?
What does that,
that technology.
Was it called magic leap?
They're going to have that technology,
which is also like a Hologram that you
can hold in your hand.
I don't know exactly how that works,
but there's another version of it that.
Is it just being fired out of your phone
or what?
Or out of a laptop.
They're being very secretive about it
and they've shown some demonstrations of
it,
but only the demonstration in the fact
that you can see like there's a little
girl that's watching a ballerina on her
bed dancing around the ballerina.
It's like four inches high.
It's incredible.
It looks amazing.
It looks like this,
like this is magic leap.
They don't explain it,
but that's going to be this.
Not Cgi.
It's not a real.
No,
no,
no.
It's not CGI.
We're looking at a little.
We're looking at a little tiny total in
the palm of someone's hand with a tinier
puppy.
Like,
look at this.
There's somehow they're going to be able
to broadcast holograms and it's not done
yet.
This is like some technology that's
proof of concept and it's in the middle
of being developed,
but then there's another one that's
similar but different.
What was the one that Google one with
the goggles.
Jamie,
do you remember that one?
Microsoft Hollow Lens.
That's it.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I'm in.
The Hollow Lens is going to be able to
change a room into a desktop.
Say like a video game that you're
playing,
like say if you want to play like call
of duty.
He play call of duty in an empty room
and the whole room will be the desktop.
I'm like,
yeah,
yeah.
They have.
Did they have demonstrations of that and
they have like,
like minority report that will you
scroll and you.
You'll be able to spin cubes around the
air and hold them and Muslim like,
look at this.
This is real.
This is how they're gonna.
Be able to do it.
This is going to be,
you need to be aware of these.
You're going to be spread,
pinch,
walk around your house.
These fucking right now,
they're goofy.
They're these giant,
huge ski goggles.
So exciting when you get,
when you're actually going to be able to
have three dimensional interactivity
with computer generated images.
I mean,
it's fairly inevitable if you think
about,
look at this,
like how she's there,
she's already have something like this.
There's a virtual reality program that
architects can use where they can walk
through the house before it's been built
based on their designs and they can be.
Yeah.
And they can,
they can do stuff like this where they
can be like,
alright,
let's just extend this wool by another
three inches and see what that looks
like.
And then they can actually take people
who are prospective buyers of properties
on three dimensional virtual reality
tours of the house that isn't even built
yet.
Look at this.
This is showing an instructional from
how to put together a pipe on a,
um,
a piece of plumbing and under your sink
and it's showing like the,
the actual applications where you could
use something for instructional
purposes.
So it's just amazing.
And this is,
this is almost inevitable,
just as crazy as what we were talking
about before.
We could send videos to other parts of
the world and skype instantaneously.
All this stuff is just next level stuff.
It's probably not that far off as well.
This isn't like in the future.
This is the kind of stuff that we're
going to be using and dealing with
probably an in 10 years.
Look at what he just showed that was,
um,
that was a three d,
virtual reality version of the,
of the surface of Mars backup a little
bit more.
Jamie like,
look at this.
That's real too.
They're going to be able to send one of
these rovers to Mars.
You're gonna.
Be able to walk around on Mars and see
it as if it's really right there.
I'll tell you what will be a game
changer for virtual reality and three
dimensional stuff like this will be
pulling be a game that when when you get
a virtual reality headset and some kind
of like suit device that allows people
to feel,
feel,
touches on actually some kind of like,
I don't know,
you know,
I messed up patient thing or they
already on you then then get linked up
to a virtual reality that actually looks
not like a three d robot human,
but kind of like an actual plausible
human being that is going to make so
much money.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well it's already.
It's already happened.
They already have that.
What does that technology called again?
The one that Duncan's always ready to.
Oculus rift,
they put the goggles on.
They have for first person interactive
porn where you put your Dick into a
machine and the machine sort of strokes
your deck and you're having sex with
someone in first person.
Yeah,
they already have it.
It's crazy.
Not only that,
it coincides.
The movements coincide to a computer
program that coincides with the action
that you're seeing.
That's what you'd want it to actually
feel.
I mean,
the advances that are coming in,
all of that kind of stuff in the next
decade is going to be mind boggling.
Well,
I think that goes back to what we're
talking about about future civilizations
that do these civilizations that exist
out there in the cosmos,
they have radar or are they transcended
that and they have.
They gone into virtual because I think
once,
once we realized that virtual can be
Avatar,
we can live inside some fantastic world.
It's so much more rewarding and exciting
and why bother with the regular carbon
based life world?
Why do we need everything to be real?
Why?
Because I can knock on this table.
Why is this table better than a table
that I feel like I can knock on,
but it's way better and every time I
touch it it gives me love.
Well this is the problem that's raised
by the film.
The Matrix,
isn't it?
I mean it become sort of a punchline of
light blue pill,
red pill,
but it's actually a profound
philosophical question.
Would you rather,
you know,
do what the bad guy does in the matrix
when he sells them all out and decides
that he's going to go back into the
matrix and have his,
his memory of the Matrix,
it'd be a raised and he'll live like the
life of a road rich celebrity,
or do you prefer the tragedy of reality
knowing that it's actually true,
but then what does it mean to say that
reality is actually true or true,
uh,
than a matrix would.
Right?
And why does it have to be?
Why does,
why does everything that's real have to
be real in only the way we understand it
today.
It's just as we've come accustomed to,
and even our own real of today has
become very bizarre.
Like the real money,
the real of money used to be.
You had a leather sack filled with gold
coins and you carry that around.
Someone could steal it from you.
Now
it's bitcoin and it's on your phone and
it's just digits,
digits that have no relationship to
anything.
It's preparing us for this inevitable
artificial weird world of something that
we have.
And it's not even artificial,
it's just a new level of life.
It's a new thing.
I think that's a really good point to
point out that it's not artificial
because look at what we're doing right
now.
We're having a conversation which is
going through technology that half
century ago would have been
inconceivable,
which is being viewed by people who are
watching us in real time and also
listened to by people who were carrying
around devices in their pockets who are
able to listen to us at any point in
time after the fact and those devices
would have been unimaginable a few
decades ago.
And yet what we're actually doing is as
authentic and as old as time.
Which is what happened to conversation.
Absolutely.
And we're having a conversation that's
fueled by this digital interface that we
have in front of us that's allowing us
to,
in real time get information in a way
that was never possible just a couple of
decades ago.
We can get all this information and what
was that?
Jamie?
Boom.
He pulls it up.
We see it up on the big screens.
I mean,
we're living right now in the matrix.
We're living in like a baby matrix.
Do you think it matters though?
I mean I have visions of like people who
just spend all their days in the,
in their basements,
plugged into a virtual reality machine.
We'd like a drip in there.
I'm providing them with sustenance and
just are off in this other universe of
their own.
How is that then people that are
listening to this while they're playing
video games and drinking mountain dew,
I mean the idea that you have to live in
the real world in order to be valid,
like why?
Well,
I mean the only reason why is because we
have needs.
We have needs for companionship and love
and friendship and it's good to go
outside and smell the fresh air,
but when they figured out a way to make
oculus rift,
you put on a headset and it's way better
than regular fresh air.
I think you're onto something with
companionship.
I think that gets to the nub of my
concern about it,
that as long as that person who's laying
in their basement plugged into an ivy
and living in a virtual reality world is
interacting with actual other human
beings who were also in that virtual
world.
I have less of a problem with it,
but if he's interacting with avatars who
aren't actual human beings but who give
him all of the feedback that we need
from companionship and he's living in a
fake world where there is no
reciprocation,
like I'm pretty confident that you
actually have a consciousness.
You might be a robot,
but I'm pretty confident that what we're
doing in your imagination.
Yeah.
You might be.
He might be dreaming right now.
Yes,
but I'm pretty confident that you are a
human being and that you are actually at
that.
I am currently engaged in an actual
conscious exchange.
Whereas if you are an Avatar and I was
in virtual reality,
I think that would be a loss.
What?
You know the concept of simulation
theory,
I'm sure.
Right?
Yeah.
The concept being for those are not
aware of it,
is that one day we were going to not
wait because I'm dumb,
but someone way smarter than us.
He's going to figure out a way to create
this sort of oculus rift thing,
next level stuff that we're discussing
right now to a point where it's you
can't
tell the difference between this and
reality.
It is inevitable.
They're going to eventually figure it
out.
Just like the stuff that we're looking
at right now is sort of the beginning
stages of this inevitable technology
that's going to transform via whatever,
whatever mode that they figured out how
to do and you're going to be able to
have an artificial reality.
It's indistinguishable from reality that
we currently experience.
If that's the case,
how do we know that we haven't already
gotten there and why would they tell
you?
Why would you not?
I mean if,
if you are in a virtual reality,
if you are in an artificial,
simulated version of the world we live
in and it's so good,
you can't distinguish,
how do you know that it's not already
happening?
How do you know what's going on right
now?
You don't,
and there's one mode of strand of
logical argument in that philosophy
which says that big,
we're probably likely to invent that
kind of technology and a fairly fairly
early in the evolution of our,
of the human rights of our civilization.
If you think about the dinosaurs,
having lived for hundreds of millions of
years,
we've only been around for a few hundred
thousand or something,
then we're probably going to get to that
point really soon.
Then this argument says it's very,
very likely that we actually are in the
simulation already because we've got
hundreds of millions of years in the
simulation and only maybe 100,000
years,
not in the simulation at the very,
very dawn of our species.
So odds are we're probably already in
it,
which I don't really buy,
but I think as acute argument,
so
con that ladies and gentlemen,
that's the end of the podcast.
Thank you very much josh.
You're awesome.
And like I said,
it's very few people that I would do a
podcast immediately after landing from
Brazil,
but I always enjoy our conversations,
checkout way the people live,
WTP,
[inaudible] dot com.
It's a good podcast.
And twitter is WTP school alive or just
send us an email and Paul Graham.
Then a dollar sign,
WTP,
underscore live at twitter and huff post
live.
Awesome.
Show and thank you.
We can do a thousand of these when I,
if I moved to La,
we'll just do it every week.
Are you thinking about it?
It's possible.
Move motherfucker.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
we'll be back.
We'll be back soon.
I forget when,
but I got a lot of good guests this
week.
Stay tuned.
Freaks.
Alright.
See you soon.
Much love.
Big Kiss to everybody.
Wow.
Yeah.